you gotta train your brain to be happy
first and then the big success comes at
the end it's not great work big success
be happy it's the reverse you've got to
train and prime your brain to think of
Happiness like a practice like a habit
like something you invest in then being
happy leads to doing great work and the
great work leads to having big success
[Music]
we all want that right but why does it
feel so complicated so elusive well many
self-help gurus present happiness as a
choice the idea that happiness can be
produced whenever we want irrespective
of circumstances others believe it's
mined in reorienting your life a
byproduct of pursuing purpose meaning
and service but today's guests my friend
Neil pasricha believes happiness lives
in the small the simple the often
overlooked daily wins
Neil pazricha is the best-selling author
of the book of awesome please welcome to
the show
that's not what happens to you it's what
you do about it Neil's the author of
nine books including the book of awesome
the happiness equation and his newest
offering our book of awesome in this
conversation I confess my cynicism in
the face of Neil's unflappable optimism
we talk about how to find deep
contentment day to day and how simply
fostering curiosity about the world
around you can produce a qualitative
Improvement in your lived experience
before we get into it this episode is
brought to you today by Roca now I get
asked constantly about the glasses that
I wear on the show Rich what are those
they are Roca always I love them they're
high performance super light great
Optics they have tons of great Styles
and uh they never slip off my face no
matter how much I sweat and you're going
to hear a little bit more about Roka
later on but right now let's invest in
the magnetic presence that is Neil
pasrichi so hit that subscribe button
and let your day be brightened
happy happy to have you here man it's
good to see you thanks for having me
yeah yeah uh it's been a long time in
the in in the making to get you here we
had to reschedule that other time so
thank you for being flexible about that
and uh
I don't know man like I have so many
ideas about how to approach this
conversation and I'm not quite sure how
to crack it but I think perhaps the best
way to to do it is to start with a
little bit of an uncomfortable
confession uh and that is that you know
how much I love you and appreciate your
work and just think the world of you and
I'm so excited to have you here uh and
yet at the same time like
I am such a cynical bastard that when I
look at you and I see somebody who oozes
with unbridled earnestness and optimism
and writes all these books about being
awesome like I can't help but get a
little bit like I contract you know I
start to feel like a little bit
uncomfortable which of course says
everything about me and and nothing
about you right so do you come up
against people who are like I don't know
about you and your whole empire of
awesome
uh yeah and uh that that emotion and
that feeling is like I I sh I share it
as well I mean the the thing is like the
origin of this idea and these these
Concepts it's not coming from a place
where I'm like unbridled
unbridledly optimistic yeah it comes
from a place where I I think I was
you know trying to trying to string a
Vine above my head and reach for
something you know it was it was really
about trying to carve a path light light
up light a little tunnel like you know
figure out a way to get to that place
I think of it as well in reflecting on
this so I had the same reaction I've
told Melvis too I have the same reaction
with the whole five second rule of
things come on man you know like let's
get real here right and that's my you
know cynicism like percolating up but I
think when you look Beyond it with
respect to your work
it's what it really is like when I get
past my own you know kind of uh
resistance to these types of ideas it's
really about noticing the small things
and cultivating a practice of
appreciation of gratitude for what you
have and and you know a sense of ah like
when we really stop and pay attention to
the world like there's plenty to you
know to see that is nourishing right and
and and extrapolating from that notion
the little things are the big things and
you talk a lot about how
if we're only looking towards you know
our kids graduation or you know walking
your daughter down the aisle at the
right like these are very few and far
between moments that may or may not
occur but we have the capacity the
ability the opportunity to have that
kind of experience in the mundanity of
of our daily lives yeah absolutely
I think I met you was a five years ago
and at the end of the couple days we
spent together I said to you something
like rich thank you so much for your
word they're so beautiful I love the way
you speak and you look them and you're
like I feel like I want to run away from
you
so uncomfortable I remember I remember
that reaction but I do think of that it
that way I do often think about the time
we have and I do often measure it and
sort of think of it in the highest
possible sense you know the global
average lifespan right now is 25 000
days the North American average lifespan
is 30 000 days and those days are finite
they are ticking the average person's
awake for a thousand minutes a day per
day that's it you do the quick math
that's why that you know that there's so
much resonance with the Oliver Berkman
book you know of four thousand weeks or
whatever it's called it's because it
just paints such a finite portrait of
what we have and if indeed it is so fine
and it is so fleeting that it's it's
incumbent upon all of us to try our best
to look for the Silver Linings the small
Pleasures those little moments of Joy
because they Infuse our days with the
richness that helps us cultivate a
positive mindset and you know what that
benefits of that are rich it's like now
we have better connections with our
family stronger connections with their
Partners deeper connections with our
children and we see the beauty in the
world around us I'm not saying it's easy
I'm not saying it's I'm not saying it's
something that you know I do every day
I'm not saying it's easy you know he be
like I'm not saying any of this stuff
I'm just saying like we owe it to
ourselves if we want to have the richest
most intentional lives possible to try
to create a practice where we're looking
for small moments of beauty yeah I think
when I think about my own kind of
predisposition you know I'm Gen X it was
sort of cool to be aloof and be ironic
and the older that I get the more I
realize that that veneer of cynicism or
that kind of default setting is actually
pretty lazy you know and it's premised
on like oh this is what cool and it's
not cool to be Earnest and have a smile
on your face and you know Embrace Life
as it comes and be optimistic but
actually and those things don't come
easy to me like I can I can I can
experience them but I only experience
them in fleeting moments or when I'm
really intentional intentional about
like trying to cultivate it in my life
which is what your work is all about
right so again back to me being the the
douchebag and all of that no no no
um not not a douchebag not you know pull
back the Judgment I mean it's it you got
an amygdala in your brain man it's to
creating fight or flight hormones all
day it's looking for problems all the
time it's not just you it's all of us
we're oriented to looking at things that
way I don't know if it's Gen X it's
unless it is like when you get a blood
test back you're looking for the high
cholesterol we all are when you get a
Mathis back you're looking for the one
you got wrong I mean I read your Memoir
and I I know that the sort of studious
like ASP you know the academic side of
you that was in there it's like
there's a biological part of this too
we're all oriented towards looking for
problems because that's how we've
survived so long so
get
don't don't call yourself a douche yeah
fair enough fair enough I mean this goes
into the self-love piece which you talk
about which is something that I'm
working on right now we can maybe get to
that
um but let's let's sort of begin with
where you know where this comes from I
know your dad was kind of a a lighthouse
as as somebody who introduced you to you
know this idea of appreciation
yeah he was um
my dad was born uh in tarantara in a
village in India in 1944
um very poor family mom died when he was
three
um the family together rang a Singer
sewing machine store and he's you know
they scrapped they saved and he was able
to get a degree in physics from the
University of New Delhi
um at the time he said I looked for
places around the world to to kind of
springboard into and he's like the
Scandinavian countries like they
wouldn't they wouldn't have immigrants
at the time so Canada and the U.S I
applied to both I got the letter back
from Canada first so I just said yes so
he came to Canada in 1966 he's 23 years
old and he came to the country with an
unbridled sense of optimism where he
said he thought I'm gonna make I'm gonna
make this work he was the very first
High School physics teacher in the
school board east of Toronto where I
grew up
he um my mom at the same time that this
was happening she was born in 1950 when
I was born in 1944 she's born in Nairobi
Kenya and she's the youngest of eight
kids and yeah and you know three boys
they get all the money they get all the
resources they get all the education
five girls nothing left you know nothing
saved for them but my mom wrote and
enter wrote an exam that everybody in
Kenya wrote when she was 12 and she got
the top Mark in the country or one of
the top marks in the country so she was
whisked off to Kenya High a boarding
school with as she calls it with the
rulers with like you know the white
major the white minority
and um when she was a teenager
graduating from there her dad passed
away Idi Amin was
um the dictator in uh nearby Uganda and
so the family was trying to like get out
of there but the way you get out of
there was like typically through like
marriage
um and her family which was wealthy lost
everything in the India Pakistan
partition wealth being held in the form
of you know jewelry and real estate so
they went from very rich to very poor
which worked out perfectly for my dad
who was poor because then when my mom
got out of East Africa went to England
my dad went back to England One Summer
as a teacher they got the Summers off
they were introduced my dad performed
the hamburger test
which you wouldn't like but he ordered
two hamburgers and one to make sure she
ate it so that he didn't marry a
vegetarian two weeks later they got
married because she ate she ate the
hamburger Rich so two weeks later their
second date their second one to argue
with that their second date was their
wedding the ultimate litmus test the
ultimate marriage material
I look at the time it was like you know
just like what am I going to be eating
for the rest of my life my parents got
married uh two weeks later they come
back to Canada and they they sort of
thump land in Oshawa Ontario a suburb of
Toronto where my sister and I are born
so that's like the background story of
kind of how it came to be and for me uh
I had a very comfortable childhood mom's
an accountant now working at General
Motors dad's that's a teacher teaching
math and physics at the local high
school
and I was a minority that's for sure it
was it was all white
um I had very little cultural exposure
because we didn't grow up in a place
where there was Indian
restaurants or clothing or or temples or
anything like that and
um
I had a pretty cozy quiet comfortable
childhood until I started hitting the
Rocks you know in my 20s later on right
and what kind of student were you
uh I would describe myself as uh
studious
um you know straight A student uh
working really hard all the time
especially in the sort of you know the
classic Indian subjects of like math
science chemistry you know physics it
was always a problem if I came home and
there was like you know two questions
wrong on the math test and we'd sit down
at the kitchen table with no pressure
there was no there's no there's no
violence there was no screaming but it
was like let's review those questions
until we get them right and so uh I
would say that the vast majority of my
faculties went towards academics so I
was not you know the the
extracurriculars were like playing the
clarinet and the band and you know
drawing cartoons on the side but I had
no like and an expectation that you
would pursue a certain uh type of career
path absolutely be a doctor yeah be a
doctor I mean it's it's the most stable
highest paying profession that's the you
know best marketed to other eligible
Indian Bachelor bachelorettes at a later
date right you know and and the sort of
fallback plan to being a doctor was like
you know the Indian like number twos
there's like lawyer no offense that
you're number two lawyer engineer
dentist you know a a practical High
salary stable job and that was always
the expectation and that's certainly
what I saw you know growing up and going
to other Indian families houses
everybody else was a doctor and I once
said to my dad this is interesting
probably as a side note I said dad why
is every other Indian family's dad a
doctor but you're a teacher and he said
when I was deciding what to do in India
in the 1950s and 60s doctors and
teachers got paid the same interesting
so it was on parity at that time at the
time in the place it was like it was
like the value of education and health
was was the same he's like I just I
guess I just picked the wrong one for
this culture although that plays into
one of your kind of tenants that you
talk about which is everybody is paid by
the hour right so when you look at the
hours of a lawyer or a doctor or a
Management Consultant or an investment
banker at least in the you know early
years of that career path and balance
that out against uh you know a teacher
in their 40-hour work week and their
unbelievable amount of you know vacation
time it all kind of balances out the
same economically I have a table in the
happiness equation that's got me more
hate mail than almost anything else
especially from teachers unfortunately
um where I show that yeah uh a Harvard
MBA making 120 grand out of grad school
makes 28 dollars an hour when you factor
how much they work and so does a teacher
when you take into account the Summers
and so on and that gets you a lot of
hate mail from teachers Bob sure but it
also doesn't take into account the the
trajectory of somebody who's on that
Management Consultant or Investment
Banking path it's like yeah sure your
first year salary is this but it quickly
escalates after that but the hours
probably stay the same yeah I know but
you could argue also the other way if I
think about my dad specifically is that
the amount of time he had before and
after school I mean he was the one that
was picking us up he was the one that's
taking us to extracurriculars my mom
would get home at five or six or seven
and my dad was like the parent that was
present especially in the Summers and so
you know what's that worth in the model
sure you know it was it was worth it was
priceless for us yeah that's a question
around values you know what are you
prioritizing for what do you what are
you aiming to optimize for in your life
is it you know Economic Security or
wealth or is it you know having a robust
you know intense relationship with your
children and your family
and those two things come into conflict
when you know
you're contemplating your career
trajectory absolutely and it's like it's
kind of an eternal question I mean the
can you have it all how do you balance
it all how do you make it all work how
do you measure how do you measure a life
and these things fold into what I think
about all the you know what I think
about all the time right and in working
our way like kind of towards up towards
like what you do now I learned a couple
things about you that I didn't know in
in the research one of which was you if
this is correct I don't I assume it is
you moved to New York City and you were
like a comedy writer for a while yeah I
didn't know that yeah so basically I I I
I graduated from high school in 1998 and
I went to Queen's University and I took
a bachelor of Commerce degree so
Business Degree four-year degree and it
pretty quickly I pretty quickly learned
and this is you know similar to what we
were talking about before a little bit
with you it was like I have this
artistic impulse that was on the side
and Queens University happened to
publish the only weekly comedy newspaper
in the country called Golden words right
and so pretty quickly my 20 hours a week
my pretty light load for for business
classes was dwarfed by the 40 hours a
week I was spending at this weekly
comedy newspaper writing articles
submitting articles it was at the time I
mean newspapers in the late 90s I mean
there were 30 40 50 pages out coming out
on a weekly basis it was a big
production with a lot of people 20 30
person staff and I loved it I got I got
I was so fulfilled intrinsically
motivated to spend time with funny
people trying to craft things that were
funny in print right and so that took me
up over the four years through a
trajectory that was tangential to my
Commerce classes where I was you know
becoming the business manager of the
paper becoming the you know an assistant
editor and then in my last year I was a
co-editor of the paper there's always
two editors every single year they
typically didn't want it to be outside
of the engineering faculty so I was it
was me and an engineer named Mike Jones
a good friend of mine and that summer
between third and fourth year I sent
applications around to any place I
thought would want somebody who had a
now a little portfolio of funny articles
right I like tried to research like
where did the Harvard Lampoon people go
you know and I I you know I applied like
Uncle John's bathroom reader in Ashland
Oregon and they're like you could come
here as we can pay you ten dollars a day
you know and at the time with the.com
kind of first Boom coming there was all
these startups there was a comedy
writing startup in New York City called
modern humorous started by some Simpsons
and Saturday Night Live guys and
ex-lampoon guys and I went down I I
rented an apartment in New York City
really really crazy story how I found
this apartment online I go up to this
apartment the first day it's a Brazilian
vegan chef and she's leaving for a month
so I've subled her apartment for a month
and she says to me um hey you might get
some weird knocks on the door here you
might you might have some people coming
by it's because the the person who
bombed the World Trade Center in 1996
used to live in this apartment I was
like what are you talking about she's
like it's a Murphy bed that comes out of
the wall you'll be sleeping in this bed
isn't that very apartment very apartment
the very apartment that I rent and she's
like I gotta go I'm off to Brazil like
but just so in case you get some weird
knocks or some funny mail right you know
that's what that's about and and the
neighbors then told me I'm 21 I'm in the
UCI drops in exactly yeah and this this
and by the way this summer I was working
in in New York rich in the story it was
to Summer of 2001. okay so so I now take
the F train every day to go from Lower
East Side over to Brooklyn where I'm
working for this comedy startup I'm
making ten dollars a day that's my
stipend stipend however you say it I got
ten it's ten dollars a day and I'm
writing articles but now I'm writing it
for money four deadlines and the
extrinsic motivator killed the passion
for me it was like oh my gosh I love
doing golden work words at Queens it was
intrinsically motivated I was running
with people I loved about what we wanted
to talk about it was so fulfilling for
me and students it became right 800
words by 5 PM about getting dumped for
cosmopolitan that was like extrinsic
guidance and it it really killed my love
of it and there's a lot of research on
intrinsic versus extrinsic motivators
yeah we could talk about if you're
interested
at Brandis now Harvard Business School
James gambarino there's great studies
that say when you're doing it because
you'll want to you're way better at it
you do it for longer you can't care
aware more so the love of the comedy
writing dissipated there okay like I
like didn't like being directed and told
for the money and the guidance and the
it was the antithesis of how I was
writing at queens and then when I come
home with the end of August yeah 9 11
happened and it just rung home to me I
literally left a month before yeah 9 11.
yeah well less than two weeks we stayed
you would have been living in the
apartment from the prior bomber yes I
mean you would have definitely gotten a
knock on the door yes yes yes yeah it
was it was that's crazy yeah and just
thinking about how young I was too like
I was also just generally overwhelmed
with being in New York like I was the
buildings was I was so loud it was so
busy like I was I was my skin felt like
it was sensitive just being outside
never mind that's experience on top of
it but even
with that realization that it wasn't for
you in retrospect because you know
looking through the rear view is always
20 20. yeah
um it it seems to me it strikes me as an
experience that was probably very uh you
know kind of fundamental to the person
you later become like you were in a
writing boot camp situation where you
had to be churning out a lot of yes
written materials sure when you decide
you're gonna write a blog post every day
for a thousand days and then ultimately
go on to become this author and write
nine books like that was pretty good
practice for just being in the flow of
like
you know create creating creating
creating creating every single day even
if it was kind of uh you know denigrated
by external factors yeah and I went to
denigrated is an interesting word just
like dampened your enthusiasm for a damp
well what I what I came to realize was
the question I there's a question I
always ask myself when I'm doing
anything which is now would you do this
for free would you do this for free when
I was running for Golden words we were
all getting paid nothing the the sort of
real newspaper on campus the journal
they paid every the editors got paid
everybody got paid there this was like
we were the same circulation but we were
not paid and so I I've held on to that
so so much so that flash forward to my
20s after I go through a divorce after
my best friend takes his own life after
I decide to try to put my mind in a
pause by starting this blog called 1000
awesome things in my late 20s after not
reading writing for viewers that's why I
decided not to put ads on the site not
to monetize the thing I thought let me
try as best I can to preserve that
original feeling of writing when I want
the way I want without having length
limits if I miss a day I design it so
that it it wasn't like there would was
going to be some I wasn't going to get
like a problem from an advertising
company saying okay you're not posting
frequently enough for for you know the
beer company or whatever it is and so
I've I've held on to that probably to my
detriment now talking but to the point
where I now don't put ads on all my
stuff and it's like now it's a problem
the other way but I've just held on to
the idea that in order for work to be
its purest creative form I like the idea
that I need to think of it as something
I would do for free I hold on to that
question because
I mentioned Teresa I'm a bit late
earlier just say you did this study at
Brandis University asking people to come
up with silly collages some people were
told they were getting rewards for the
collages some people were not when they
asked independent judges to evaluate the
collages guess which ones were more
creative the ones that were not told
they were getting a reward they were
more creative right James gambrino did
the study that has like I think 11 year
old girls can you tutor younger girls
can you tutor younger girls well there's
piano math whatever one group of girls
was told they were going to get a movie
ticket for doing it spend half an hour
you're gonna get a movie ticket the
other one was not told that the ones
that were not told that they were going
to get a reward spent longer took more
care and had you know the people that
they were they were tutoring did better
at the end of it and so I really hang on
to this intrinsic versus extrinsic
motivation as a bit of a guiding tool
for me I'm not saying it's perfect but
it has become something that I hold on
to because of that original golden words
versus modern humorist experience yeah
it's uh it's uh it's really important to
think about those things and it's
something that I spend a lot of time
thinking about in the context of like
doing this thing that we're doing right
now like I started it 10 years ago I Did
It For the Love of it I did it for a
number of years without not only did I
not make any money doing it it didn't
occur to me that you could and then it
grew to the point where
um you know it was it was viable to be
monetized in a responsible way and I had
to make the decision like if I wanted to
do that and I actually needed to because
we needed the money
um and so it's a balance so it's not a
binary thing it's like yes this is a
commercially viable entity but I would
sit down and talk with you for a couple
hours for free so how do you do both
right how do you balance both and so
when you when you allow the the Commerce
aspect of it to kind of come into the
equation then it becomes about figuring
out how to balance all of that
understanding that there are not
necessarily concessions but like I have
to do meetings and do phone calls and do
intake on and make decisions about which
sponsors I want to work with and which
ones I don't and there's a time
consuming aspect of that but at no
juncture has there ever been a situation
in which a sponsor has compromised the
quality or the Integrity of the show
like there is a little bit of a church
and state with respect to that that
we've been able to maintain but you know
it is something that I think about so
it's not just interest intrinsic versus
extrinsic like these two things like
never intersect
um but it's about like how you kind of
um live with both of them at least in
the context of this thing yeah and you
know I'd be lying if I didn't say like I
occasionally look at the rank I want to
see like well how's the show doing you
know like I can get caught up in all of
that right but I know myself well enough
and and you know once I start doing that
I become less happy yeah and it becomes
less about
um the reasons why I got into this to
begin with which was to have nourishing
amazing conversations that I get to
share that people out in the world seem
to extract value from and that's really
what it's about in the minute I lose
sight of that and start focusing on
those externalities is the moment at
which the this thing kind of begins to
lose its its soul and its reason for
being you are so wise the way you
articulate it and the way you embrace
the complaint of it and the way you can
have a rhythmic uh almost like almost
like a surfing of of these two sides
right the artistic side and the
commercial side how they come together
on the show and just in general
and I'll add on top of that and I'll ask
you this question back it's like from
what I see from my perspective is just
like a person living in the world it's
like the advertise the the capitalism is
uh aggressive and it will want the front
of your podcast then it will want the
middle of your podcast and then then I
will want pieces of of and I don't mean
your pockets but just yeah you want our
minds and so what guiding principles do
you use you know from now into the
future because you know we've had
conversations over the years where like
elements that were sacrosanct I think to
use your word it's like there's a
constant aggressiveness to this late
stage capitalism that we're part of and
that it's getting more difficult as a
consumer and especially I'm assuming as
a Creator to try to balance the demands
of right those capitalist forces with
what you're trying to produce
artistically yeah it does it does get
tricky you know like at some point like
imagine a scenario where you know
suddenly you know podcasting is like
this medium that everyone's like to and
there are these big companies out there
you know Spotify and Amazon and Sirius
and I heart radio and for a minute
they're dangling like big deals out
there like hey come with us and you know
we'll help you grow your show uh but
there are concessions that you have like
if you do that then suddenly they're
going to be like we need you to do ads
for McDonald's or you know like in all
the other I heart radio shows so yeah or
or start inserting ads that aren't your
voice but are for products that you
don't necessarily believe in and then
you find yourself thinking well at what
price would I be able to sleep at night
with something like that so that's where
it becomes like pernicious and it kind
of creeps up on you slowly and then you
wake up one day and you realize like wow
like this isn't why I got into this or
you know the heart and soul the spirit
with which you know this thing you know
the reason why this thing became uh
important to a certain number of people
um suddenly is lost in all of that and
then you have nothing
so what do you hold on to what are the
principles or do or do Nots or you know
because that must be tempting not just
for you but just as a Creator I mean I
think people are creating things in
general the truth Neil is that like
we're doing great like we don't need to
do any of those kind of deals and we're
in a very privileged situation in which
we can pay our bills and I can pay you
know everyone that you see here around
in this room and works very hard to
create something of of of of of high
quality
um and and the more that I root myself
in in the love of it and the reason why
I got into it to begin with that
Curiosity like how can I grow what is
lighting me up who are the people I
really want to talk to not because
they're big fancy people out in the
world and I know if I have them on that
I'll get attention or it will grow the
audience but truly like when it's coming
from the heart that I know I'm on the
right path and that's like kind of
playing a long game like you're not
hacking a system for the purpose of
growth and under understanding that
growth isn't necessarily the most
important metric right the important
metric is making sure that you stay in
love with this thing because that energy
people feel it like they know whether
that's true or or kind of um
uh artificial I suppose and uh and then
and then you know making sure that that
uh
that what was I gonna say I lost my my
train of thought but it had to do with
um
uh
you know following your curiosity right
and and oh and it was it's about like
making sure that you're that you're
nourishing the people who already care
about what you're doing and not worrying
so much about growth right right right
right and that love that you say is not
dissimilar to the would I do it would I
do this for free question that I try to
keep as a steering guide for myself yeah
you know if you could keep saying I'll
do this I could I would do this for free
then that is a nice sign that you're
doing it for intrinsic purposes at the
end of the day but there is so much
intrinsic I'm sorry extrinsic uh
impulsing out there right now more than
ever you talk about like hey like it
used to be you know the New York Times
bestseller once a week you could see
these lists now Amazon refreshes it
constantly you can get caught up in that
charts everybody's got you know however
many people follow them on all these
social media it's like all of that you
know is a distraction from the the the
the work itself and you know trying to
stay connected to the purity of that is
something that I feel like you have done
in incredible job of
um and it's not for lack of of like
intention like you've created all of
these systems to insulate yourself from
all of those impulses that can lead you
astray so that you stay rooted in like
what's important to you such that the
time that you spend really is dedicated
to the
um it's it's in line with your value set
and is dedicated to the things that you
know you care about the most
absolutely a hundred percent and a lot
of the systems are designed because I've
fallen off the leg and I don't like the
way I feel after I fall off the wagon I
mean you start with the morning system
that I have for myself this two minute
morning idea why do I why every single
day when I wake up and I know you do a
morning Pages thing yourself but why
every single day when I wake up do I not
check my phone do I not even I'm staying
at a hotel room last night to come here
the phone's plugged into the bathroom
like I can't even have my phone near me
because I'm so addicted to it if I open
up my eyes and it's right beside me of
course I'm gonna check it there's 12
texts waiting there's 12 of these
there's 12 of that so I have to start
the day with this two minute morning
practice I grab a pen and grab a piece
of paper or I use the yellow Journal
that you have there but typically it's
on a pen and piece of paper I just say I
will let go of
I am grateful for and I will focus on
and those three phrases I'll tell you
they wipe a wet Chamois across my mind
every single day and I think you got a
special moment in the morning when you
talk about systems and you wake up it's
like you really you when you wake up you
haven't been jostled senseless yet by
anything that anyone's trying to tell
you you got a really small window
because as soon as you touch your phone
even as soon as you look at a paper as
soon as you it's as soon as you turn on
the TV it's now it's it's something
pushing its information to you but when
you're the most you it's like right when
you open your eyes and so right when I
open my eyes
the first thing I do every single day I
will let go of
the worry I feel about how I'm going to
perform on the ritual podcast today like
I'm I'm it's a it's a gigantic pockets
it's a huge show I will but I'll write
I'll I'll write it down right I am
grateful for okay and I'll I'll say a
bunch of things about my kids or the
smell of my wife's neck I wrote today
like I write little little bits and
pieces The View out of this hotel room
what a cool view I can see a Ruddy Duck
out my window a Ruddy Duck by the way
currently breeding with the Blue Bell
it's a pretty special bird rich and I
could see well when I woke up this
morning it was pretty cool and then I
will focus on I will focus on you only
got a thousand minutes you're awake a
day that's it thousand minutes about 16
and two-thirds hours the average person
you gotta have one Focus otherwise again
you know the book will power by Roy
balmeister and John Tierney it's like
you got decision fatigue coming on her
ears we got hundreds of decisions to
make a day so if we don't write one
thing we're gonna focus on we're lost at
the end of the day you've got nothing
done those three prompts help give me
one system they're one system I use of
many in order to help give me a fighting
chance of winning the morning and then
the morning wins the day you know so
it's like just trying to get some of
these little snowballs rolling so that
they end up having disproportionate
benefits not unlike the Habit work
that's very popular right now
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
Jonathan Fields our our mutual friend uh
said said about you that you are the
freest and most rule-based person that
he knows right and there's something
interesting about that dichotomy it's
not that different from like Jocko
willink who says discipline is freedom
like there is freedom once you set up
these rules and when I hear you talk
about all the systems that you create
and all these rules that kind of Drive
um how you spend your time and and
reduce that decision fatigue I can find
myself a little bit overwhelmed like oh
my God like you know how do you like his
life is so regimented in that regard
like it feels somewhat robotic but then
I realize like oh I have rules you know
like I don't think maybe I don't like
think about them or like talk about them
in the way that you do but I do have
certain Like rules that drive my
decisions that make
uh that make my day kind of flow in a
certain direction generally like like
what well
like I don't I don't drink alcohol like
they're binaries it's like or or uh you
know I don't schedule meetings or phone
calls before noon that's a great when I
break that rule you know life intervenes
I don't always but I try to hold that
like the rules break you know like
they're guys they're gonna protect
morning hours things like that you know
um you have it sounds like you have
rules early hours of the day are for
like journaling and writing and
meditation and training and things like
that so maybe they're a little bit more
vague than yours you got rules around
your food yeah rules around the food
like no animal products like it's just
buy like talk about decision fatigue
like that kind of makes it easy like
okay so I don't have to really think
about that like I just don't do that so
that removes that aspect of of like
where are we gonna eat or what are we
going to do or should I do this or
should and holding on to these rules I
mean I had this I've had the same thing
although when I'm traveling I've had the
same thing for breakfast for 15 years
exact same Shake exact same ingredients
I might change the food some people
would say like oh you've just been at
like to the point of being robotic like
doesn't this make you some sort of
automaton like this is you're living a
spreadsheet life Neil
[Laughter]
I wrote I wrote the happiness equation
in a spreadsheet of course you did
yeah but but it is to it is to the so
for example though I will say so you
know about my family contract right yes
you know that lesson I I have I I say to
everybody you write a contract with your
company they give you a piece of paper
it tells you how much money what your
job title is who's your boss what your
expectations are you sign this piece of
paper you go home you got no equivalent
like balance creating contract with your
home life right that was a a a lesson
that somebody told me when I got this
big job offer at Walmart at the time was
like director of leadership I was going
to be the director and the guy's like
well are you gonna take it I was like
well of course it's a home run it's like
there's gonna be more travel it's gonna
be more hours like what's What's it
gonna be like at home and so I created a
family contract we still write and sign
it every year we've got four bullet
points in it lastly and I so Flash
Forward for those that didn't catch that
I was divorced like I'm now remarried
I'm now remarried and and it's like
maximum four nights away per month right
minimum four family days per month those
are days where it's just Leslie and I
our kids nothing else no
no extended family no no no no no
birthday parties no trips no ideally no
screen so family times a minimum of four
date nights per month which has become
difficult lately but we're working on so
prioritizing time just the two of us
right
and you're looking at me with this funny
face no go ahead no I want to hear it
all okay okay
um so I've got the I've got the knights
away I've got so four four maximum four
four nights away I've got the four I've
got the four family days I've got I've
got the four I've got the four date
nights and why do I why do I put these
structures in place well because then
guess what Rich when I get an offer to
come fly out and do a podcast or come
and do a speech or something it's like a
really nice and easy filter to send it
right through that system and say well
do I have four nights away this month or
not yet if I don't well that that's a
possible acceptance if I do it's an
automatic no and then guess what that
enables it enables
the other part which is I have four
minimum four Untouchable days per month
which is one per week and Untouchable
day is a day where i'm on unreachable
Untouchable by anyone in any way any
form which is where the best creative
work comes from and so
um yeah it's a maximum of this one but
it's it's to create you mentioned why is
there so because I have the time and
space to create them because the rules
allow for that freedom right so I agree
with Jocko I agree that discipline is
freedom I never met the guy but this is
sounding good to me and I I do that
because it enables the the space that I
think we are losing in society today
desperately there is a lack of space all
over the place mental space physical
space mind share it's going down fast
and so these rules are their their arms
on the gates like they're ways to keep
that precious Sacred Space so I was able
to go bird watching this morning before
coming here walking around the pond
behind the nice hotel that you told me
to stay in and I loved it because I had
created a rule that this day was about
this conversation in the morning is
empty you know emptiness creates
space for the nourishing the nourishment
as you call it of a fresh air of of
getting out of my species by looking at
another animal I've gotten into bird
watching as you can tell uh you know of
breathing in the phyton size the lower
the cortisol and adrenaline so I'm not
as nervous and it just is a wonderful
way to live so ultimately these are
things in service of living a rich
intentional life which is what I'm
ultimately doing my icky guy is trying
to help people live an intentional life
trying to help people live happy lives
where do I start with me right what
helps the rules yeah that's beautiful
and the key word being intentionality
right I think we all you know have
certain intentions
um that drive our decision making but by
and large we live reactively and I'm
speaking for myself I I know we all just
bouncing around and and and maybe not as
in command of how I allocate our most
precious resource which is my time and
my attention on a daily basis and those
rules really help Drive the decisions to
make sure that you're valuing that
precious asset and then deploying it as
effectively strategically as possible to
move your life in the right direction
and to honor those things that you are
clear that are the things that you care
about most right and then I have this
other side of my brain where I'm like if
I wrote up a contract and said this is
what we're going to do and it's going to
be like this done I handed it to Julie
and I was like sign like let's negotiate
this and sign it she'd be like get the
[__] out of here like you know like
there's also a there's also something to
be said for like like you do acknowledge
and care about being in in a state of
awe and wonder and presence and and an
acknowledgment that like being present
in that place of receiving uh provides
space for you know magic and mystery and
the unexpected thing that isn't on the
spreadsheet or kind of uh you know lives
outside the boundaries of your rubric
yeah and if you're too regimented like
this is what I'm doing and I'm glad this
and I got this and then this hour I do
this and this then you're robbing
yourself of of your availability for
that so is that like how do you like I
you know I would imagine that you think
about that a little bit like I do it's
in that space like you have those days
where you're like I'm unavailable like
this is where I'm living in my ex my
expanded state of
receptivity and creative cultivation and
soulless and the me like sort of
courting The Muse I mean when I was at
Walmart I I had a boss Named Dave cheese
right he was the CEO of Walmart Canada
at the time and people I was mystified
about the fact that this guy never
answered email he just never answered
he's like you sent him an email it was
like sending an email to like a black
hole wouldn't come back and people were
always like you know he can do that
because he's the CEO but what they were
missing was the fact that no he's he's
the CEO because he did that all the way
up his career trajectory there is
something about figuring out the right
way to decide what to do before you have
to do it each time for me it comes down
to a two by two Matrix that I've
designed called the time versus
importance Matrix I think every decision
that comes to us Rich has takes a
certain amount of time and it's of a
certain importance if you think about
time and importance like let's put time
on the y-axis
low high that's put importance on the on
the x-axis low high anything that takes
a low amount of time and is of low
importance we should automate we should
not think about it's low in time and
it's low in importance
so
I wear the same thing for every single
speech that I ever give I don't I don't
I wear the same shoes I wear the same
jeans I wear the same shirt I have the
same I don't think about it it's a it's
a it's an automated system same as my
breakfast okay a cup of water shake a
turmeric shake a cinnamon throw in a
couple a frozen banana is this Frozen
it's the same thing every single day I
automate that now this is the
interesting part about this two by two
Matrix what do you do about the decision
this is the what affects all of us a lot
which are
uh you know really important really
important but they don't take very long
saying hi to your team when you walk in
here saying goodbye before you leave
those ones you effectuate that means
just do it get it done pick up your kids
from daycare drop them off those are
things that are important they don't
take very much time what about the third
thing this is maybe the most important
one things that are
um
high on time but low on importance high
on time low on importance the best
example is email takes forever people
are doing email all day the average
person's getting 147 emails a day it
takes so much time you look at people's
time charts they're like checking email
all day but it's not that important well
this this one needs a regulated
regulated fenced-in area okay
I did this study on email it turns out
that the two best hours of a data check
email are from 9 to 10 in the morning
and from four to five PM why because you
create for yourself a six hour email
free window in the middle of the day an
oasis that's email free but you still
have two hours on email which is like
good for if you have like a knowledge
working type of job right those three
things the outsides of the two by two
Matrix where you're automating you are
effectuating and you are regulating and
I'll give you another example regularly
and just before I close that off it's
like Leslie and I we first when we first
bought a house
um is an old house things were going
wrong all the time what was driving us
the most crazy and Baddie Rich was
always like oh my gosh there's a wobbly
patio stone oh my gosh there's a door
that's squeaky oh this light bulb needs
to be changed every single day we had
something to fix on our house so then I
sent her an invite
Julie went like this I sent her a
recurring invite every it's the first
Saturday morning of every month for half
a day it's called Old House morning she
accepts it it's recurring every month
and guess what we made a list on the
inside of one of our kitchen cupboards
anything that goes wrong in the house we
write it on the list now we've regulated
fixing all the stuff in our house into
one half day per month it makes the
other 29 and a half days a month free
discipline is freedom it makes the other
29 and a half days a month without the
worry of the patio stone and the squeaky
door because you regulate it into one
specific window now what's the beauty of
this model again it's time versus
importance every single decision low
time and low importance automated right
then you got regulated then you got
effectuated it creates space to debate
the things that really matter it creates
space for the high time high importance
decisions that none of us have the
mental capacity to wrestle with you say
all the time conversation matters and
you get into these dark beautiful thorny
nuanced places in your conversations and
this is partly why people like me love
this show because you go there but that
space that mental space to debate where
I want to live who do I want to be with
whom I really am what job lights me up
we don't give ourselves enough space to
do them because we're handling all those
low-time loan Force decisions yeah I
mean that's a really important point
we're constantly distracted and we fill
up any opportunity to do that kind of
work with additional distractions
because we have phones and that can
entertain us and when we're standing in
line or whatever and so never before in
the history of humanity have we had to
exert such discipline to craft
boundaries to carve out time for that
type of work and uh you know if you're
not like super intentional and perhaps
even goal-oriented like I have this
thing I want to achieve whether it's I
want to write a book or whatever it's
some creative thing
you know those goals will drive a
recognition of the need for that type of
carving out of time but for the you know
average person who's working a job and
is kind of doing fine or whatever and
it's busy and it's like I'm just trying
to like do my thing and raise my kids
and you know maybe have a little bit of
fun on the weekend it's it's harder to
say like hey you know like they don't
have this situation where they're going
to be able to carve out a day you know
off their phone where they're going to
like walk around Toronto right just
think right deep thoughts right you know
like you like that's a very you have a
life that affords you that because
you've made certain choices and you're a
writer and this is what you do but how
does that impact like the average person
like how do they think about how to how
to you know craft you know their own
version of what you're talking about
that is functional in the construct of
their their you know current situation
absolutely so there's two things there
one is I will say I do get up all the
time I was like you could do this
because you're a writer no and I do
argue back yeah I get I am a writer
because I make the space having said
that I also worked at Walmart for 10
years 10 years a corporate job office
job you know I I was working in
leadership development tell the story
because like like we haven't even gone
into that I mean you so we we kind of
left off with you you know decamping New
York City right before you know 9 11.
but the other thing I didn't I didn't
know about you Neil is that you went
back to Toronto and then you you owned a
Quiznos franchise yes this is true this
is true right yeah yeah there's a lot
there's a lot of missing people for
going to Harvard Business School yes
that's right yeah we're filling it all
into that okay so so
um just because I don't want to lose
those people that are like wait a minute
he didn't answer
maybe we don't like maybe we can park
that but I want to go I'm happy to go
back into that but I'll just say
Untouchable lunch that's what I was
gonna say at Walmart we all went out for
lunch we go to the sushi place everyone
takes their phone at the time it was
blackberries everyone takes their
blackberries we cram to the back of
someone's Toyota we all goes for sushi
people are checking their phones in the
blackberries for work the whole time
what's the boss saying is the boss
texting me do I need to rush back I got
this meeting at one o'clock it's 12 58
we gotta rush back
practice an Untouchable lunch practice
leaving the phone on your desk and
walking out of the building for one hour
that's the practice the practice is just
can you do without a phone for an hour
can you walk in the path down the street
from your office just to practice an
hour if you can do that then let's see
if you can do some tradesies with your
boss with your co-workers say I'm going
to take one afternoon to be Untouchable
on my work at home I might work wherever
you don't even know where I'm going to
work let's see what happens and if you
come back Wednesday morning and you've
got some good ideas this is the way to
sell it back into your boss he's like
hey why don't you take try that too
we'll take a half day off a week where
we each try to this Untouchable time so
I just want to say for those that were
kind of latching on to your question
here let's just baby steps baby just
start small
Neil pass reach at age 20 age 23 comes
back from comes back from Manhattan
finishes finishes his Queen's Commerce
degree and my very first job I don't
know if you know this was I was doing
brand marketing for Covergirl and Max
Factor makeup in Toronto I did not know
that so I can tell you all about the
lengthening volumizing and separating
properties of mascara if you're
interested I was running 1200 skus for a
Covergirl okay I thought it was a
PowerPoint job Rich it turned out to be
an Excel job it was like crunching data
on price changes and it was like
not very creative and I I failed at it
completely i i i they didn't like me I
didn't like them I was put on a pip you
know performance Improvement plan within
months which is a fancy way of saying
we'd like to fire you but we don't have
enough of a paper trail let's build one
together you know so it was like not
going well so now I'm looking for
something else to do when this job was
not working out well and I bit into a
quiznosed sub sandwich one day and I was
like this is the most delicious sandwich
I have ever eaten I talked to the local
franchisee in ashwintero he was telling
me his sales per square footage or
double that of subways it's a brand that
no one's heard of Quiznos it's 2002 and
so I teamed up with my dad took a big
loan out of the bank and I bought a
quiznosub franchise
at age 23 and I was the owner operator
manager lease signer wow managing hiring
a whole team of teenagers to work there
and I ran
a minute through a minute through the
oven for some warm toasty love and Rich
that was our slogan we put it on a big
sign and we sold mesky chickens and
Black Angus steaks and delicious veggie
sandwiches with guacamole and I
absolutely loved it and it lost a ton of
money really
so you go
so you write your application to Harvard
Business School talking about how you
lost a bunch of money owning a Quiznos
franchise well the cool thing about what
you so so you're like okay why'd you go
from Quiznos to Harvard how that how
that happened well basically a year and
a half into running the quiz on
subfranchise it was pretty clear that
this was just not look I did say I loved
it we had no turnover the staff all we
had so much fun there it was just a joy
being in that restaurant we had it was
I learned how to manage a team I learned
how to hire when I asked the head office
how do you hire people they said hire
the prettiest girls the head office told
me that over the phone that was their
that was their guide this is 20 years
ago that was their hired the young
pretty girls I was like this isn't gonna
this isn't gonna work so I came up with
a whole hiring practice where I I asked
people one question what's something
you're passionate about tell me about it
for five minutes if the passion was
demonstr like it was like they were
excited I was like I could probably get
them excited about sandwiches then I
took them to another Christmas sub saw
how they ordered the menu from the other
side how do they interact from a
customer service perspective then I gave
them I designed a sandwich exam so I had
them memorize the recipes for the
sandwiches fill out an exam if they got
over a certain percentage as a team of
people then they their their staff
discount kicked in well this hiring
practice turned out to be so popular
that they implemented it around the
chain and there was lots of things like
that it was like customer service I
called that office like what's the
customer service policy they're like I
don't know just give them a free
sandwich
like if somebody complains I was like no
we got to come up with a practice we
came up with a practice called last
listen apologize solve thank we branded
on stickers we stuck it on the cash
register my very first day that we were
open
a woman calls me up the very first day
and saying my whole family's puking at
home right now thanks to four expired
chunk filled chocolate milks we just
bought from your store
I was like listen I'm so sorry I
apologize that's the second part solve
what's your address
I deliver a six foot sub to her that
afternoon on a big wooden plank to try
to make it up to her and then we add
thank thank you because of you we've now
added check the expiry dates of the
chocolate milk to our morning checklist
so that last process also got
implemented around the chain so it was a
failure financially but it was a real
growth from a leadership perspective and
I got to develop some instincts and some
ideas for how you form and shape these
things inside organizations so after I
sold the criminal sub franchise and was
deciding what to do next Quiznos called
me up and said why don't you be our
director of operations so then become
the director of operations for Quiznos
head office oh wow that's interesting so
you're this lowly franchisee but you're
actually like drafting policy that's
getting implemented across this gigantic
Corporation I made a big uh poster
called the life cycle of a j cloth
because people were just using them and
throwing them I was like no no no no it
goes from the tables to the back bins to
the bleach buckets like we have to make
them last four days we can 4X our usage
on on J claw so yeah I was doing stuff
like that then I worked for direct a
Christmas Canada as director of
operations and then
you know grad school often rich is like
you don't know what you're gonna you
know you don't know what you want to do
so you may as well delay the decision by
going to school and because I had
specialized early and I don't I wouldn't
do that again now like specializing in a
discipline like business from when I was
18 years old you know
you have you know I I envy the people
that have had like you a wider breadth
of of learning at that age but I
specialize early so in my mind I was
like well if I'm going to do a master's
I guess it's got to be business I can't
quite go into astronomy or or Philosophy
from here
and so I uh you know stirred up all
those wacky experiences I had the comedy
writing down in New York City the brand
marketing and recover girl and Max
Factor the running of a quiz and it
turns out that a lot of Business Schools
base their application base their
admissions although it's a black box
they based on you know there there are
spaces uh available for like the weird
applicant because everyone else is
coming from consulting or banking yeah
and so if you have just like this Molly
Crew type resume you do stand out and so
if you can combine that with at the time
for me it was like you know do a good
job on the GMAT at the time it was like
a you know aptitude test like the LSAT
or whatever and get some nice references
you're in and so I was very shocked and
surprised when I got a letter saying
you're in and I was delighted when the
letter then said hey how much money did
you make the last three years
and I was like none because I had this
bankrupt company and I was in school and
stuff like that and I had this job that
I quit really soon and they're like
congratulations we have an 18 billion
dollar endowment you're so poor that
we're gonna pay for you so I got I also
got and I wasn't it wasn't expecting
that so then so then I also got to go
there and they covered it because when
you go to undergrad they ask for your
parents tax returns when you go to grad
school they ask for your tax returns
because now you're right now you're an
adult so you got your Harvard graduate
school education subsidized scholarship
massive amounts of Lucky breaks all
stirred in there yeah yeah and then you
you go you have that experience and you
uh end up not going to Wall Street or
the management consulting route because
you went up at Walmart not in the front
of the store greeting people but in the
back office
well because the the fellowship I got at
Arbor was called the John McArthur
Fellowship which was the the dean of HBS
of Harvard Business School from 1989 to
95 was a Canadian guy who set up the
scholarship for all Canadians who made
less than a certain amount of money to
get a free ride I write a five-page
thank you letter this guy telling him
like thank you so much for paying for me
to come here he invites me to lunch and
he's like how's it going on campus and
to your point about the Wall Street jobs
the iBanking jobs I said it is stressful
here I am in my third week of a two-year
program and already every single night
is like whining and dining with McKinsey
you know like we're hanging out with
millionaire bankers and Consultants with
black bags under their eyes hoping that
we can become one of them too I'll never
forget going out for dinner with
McKenzie until two in the morning
sparking conversation smart people
having great conversations but when the
thing ended at 2 am they were all going
back to work and that's what stuck and
lodged in my head the most like at 2AM
they're all like jumping on conference
calls with Shanghai and like I was like
oh my gosh I cannot do this and he said
to me Neil you are like he said you were
like a horny guy outside a beach and you
see those Bathing Beauties in there and
you're at a fence
and there's a thousand people the class
of Harvard Business School you don't
feel special when you get there there's
900 people there's 900 people that get
in you're with 900 to a thousand people
all trying to get one of those bathing
beauties the bathing beauties were the
metaphor for those jobs those million
dollar kind of Wall Street jobs he's
like but when they open the fence
everybody's gonna run in chasing those
same 10 jobs teaching the same 10
Beauties and you know what even if you
land one of them which you probably
won't you're going to be looking over
your shoulder the whole time
so I was like what are you trying to
tell me this is the former dean of the
place there's a whole career services
department full of dozens of people all
orchestrated towards like this whole
rhythm of like career visioning and
networking nights all the stuff and he's
like tell me to light a match to it all
he's like get off the beach
I was like what do you mean he said go
to the library call up the companies
that are broken have PR problems that
are bankrupt that aren't flying in Jets
to Harvard Business School because they
don't have the time or money or ability
to come here and you call them up and
then if you get into one of those
companies they give you a job where you
have meaningful work they listen to you
they take your ideas and you know what
you become a big fish in a small pond it
increases your academic self-concept and
you can ride that for years while
learning the most so I never applied to
another job from Harvard Business School
ever again instead I came up with a
spreadsheet of companies that I thought
were going through difficult times at
the time Walmart had a pretty rough
reputation and was a sizable enough size
to Warrant somebody potentially working
in there in leadership development which
is the field I was interested in right
so you go there and this idea of being a
big fish in a small pond becomes another
one of your kind of core tenants that
that you speak about and and kind of
advocate
um and it's interesting because like
I've I've had decisions in my life where
I had to decide whether I wanted to
explore being a big fish in a small pond
or a small fish in a big pond and I've
I've made the latter you know on
occasion I've had occasion to make
different decisions but you know my
thinking at the time was you'll never
know unless you put yourself in that
position like you go and be a small fish
in a big pond and you will quickly get
feedback as to whether you know you'll
be able to compete at that level or not
but if you don't and you go be a big
fish in a small pond you're robbing
yourself of that opportunity to really
explore the fullest capacity of your
potential
absolutely and it's different times in
different places and different people
I'll tell you for me as a cracked up
like low self-confidence 25 year old at
Harvard Business campus that advice was
like a bomb on an itch on my chest
because I felt so
dumb at all these I I felt so I'm coming
here from a sandwich restaurant that
didn't work out very well teaching
people how to use J cloths better yeah
but you were probably studying business
earlier than a lot of these guys too
you're selling yourself short well
either whether I was selling myself
store or not I'll tell you my confidence
was extremely low it was extremely low
and the proof of this 1984 paper on is
it better to be a big fish sell small
yeah shows that our academic
self-confidence can increase for up to
10 years after we're out of the pond so
for me it's like I use this
instructional tool of finding small
ponds in my life when I find that my
it's my confidence and my work that I
want to start flash forward to when I
was becoming you know when the book of
awesome came out in 2010 I know we're
jumping here but now I'm in my late 20s
uh I'm I'm at Walmart
um I get married
um we buy a house
um we're talking about having kids and
it it doesn't work it doesn't work out
you know my wife tells me after two
years like
I don't love you anymore I don't want to
be I don't want to be in a relationship
with you and as that's happening and
that marriage is crumbling I'm having to
sell my house my best friend Chris Kim
you know at the time he's going through
severe severe depression and takes his
own life that's where from those Embers
I start up this tiny blog called 1
000awesomethings.com as a way to try to
Prime my brain for positivity okay
but I was telling the fine small pond
story when that turned into this book
called The Book of awesome which came
out in 2010 I was encouraged to start
going on speaking tours to talk about
positivity around the world and they
want to throw me into a paid speaking
category with the the amount I was going
to get paid for speech was like I was
like this I feel very uncomfortable this
is way too much who else is speaking in
this category and they're like this
best-selling author this Olympian this
and I was like whoa whoa whoa whoa like
what's the smallest lowest speaking
range you have and they're like well
this is the you know this is the
smallest it's like five five thousand
dollars I think at the time they're like
it doesn't make sense for us working on
commissions to like do all this work for
less than that it's like put me there so
I was speaking in boardrooms for 50
people working out my ACT my like
confidence in though that's what I'm
saying a low pressure situation that's
exactly what I'm saying so I'm saying
this fine Small Ponds adage is helpful
when you think you might need it and so
maybe for ritual the the great you know
Stanford you might not have and like
look you know yeah so I was like oh I
can go oh should I go to Stanford and be
like the tiniest fish in this massive
pond at the time I was like well I'll
never know if I don't and I went and you
know I don't know that it worked out
perfectly you know like maybe it would
have been much better had I you know
gone in a different direction I don't
know
um but I would say to your point like
that's not dissimilar from when I
started this podcast 10 years ago and I
was listening to podcasts and I could
put up episodes and there was like very
little risk like it wasn't it was like
not really anyone was listening and I
was able to like do it for the love uh
you know be be uh I don't know was
podcasting like a a small pot I guess it
was at the time at the time I could be
uh not even a big fish like a small like
a small fish in a small pond and you
know work it out and figure out you know
what my thing was
um and and then it kind of grew around
me organically but
I do feel I do see the value in of
course like you know putting yourself in
a situation to succeed especially if you
feel vulnerable or whatever to boost
your confidence in in a real way not in
a in an artificial or manufactured way
yeah yeah and once again you've added
the layers of complexity and Nuance that
are really good below my little try kind
of your zingers my zingers you got a lot
of zingers but where were we before that
I don't even know but we were talking
about
um
uh
oh you going to Walmart being at Harvard
Business School
um
starting the blog you know doing it out
of like when I when I think about that
story of you going through the divorce
and suffering you know the loss of your
friend and and being in this kind of
dark place having this job and and you
know having your kind of needs being met
but but having this desire to
um you know process these challenging
challenging emotions try to find a way
to grasp onto something that had light
attached to it
um you know starting a blog and
committing to like I'm going to put up a
blog post every day about one awesome
thing
seems like it's a you know it's like a
practice it's like I'm going to meditate
every day or I'm going to do this one
thing that I have control over I don't
have control over how many people are
going to read this thing but I can
control doing this one thing
um that that actually you know perhaps
could lead me to processing all of this
and and helping me to feel better yeah
yeah and at the time you know you think
about as 2008 here blogs were uh you
know that was the blog it was the blog
era but I did a couple things in the
design of that website that maybe are
hard to see from now at the time they
were unique one was I did it as a
countdown not as a count up so it was
called 1 000 things but my first post
which was number one thousand broccoli
flower the strange mutant hybrid child
of Nature's ugliest vegetables then
number 999 so I always had this like
finite slow building pressure towards an
actual end date so I had the end date
when I started like so I started it June
20th 2008 I knew the thing was going to
end May 15 2012. I had that
mathematically worked out because it
added to me a little bit of forced
positive pressure and
and the WordPress blogs at the time you
could and I typed in how to start a blog
into Google I pressed I'm feeling lucky
WordPress was number one so it was I
didn't know how to do it it was just
like okay I'll start that way and
um
you know WordPress I think you can set a
timer so I set the timer for 1201 am
every single day so it was a forced
little pressure cooker to be like okay
one pose it could be a one-liner or it
could be you know a thousand word essay
about the joys of old dangerous
playground equipment burning your legs
in hot slides falling into cigarette
butts and milk thistles like kids with
cats and I was like you know I could go
on a big long rant or I could give
myself an excuse and just say hey a post
could just be one line
and so yeah starting that thing out it
was nobody was nobody was reading it I
always joked that my mom sent it to my
dad and the traffic doubled overnight
and eventually you know you know this
feeling
um the ver the moment of truth is when
you get a comment from a stranger
you know the moment it's like you find
out that like someone you don't know is
is reading this thing and then it just
got you know bigger and bigger I was
getting
five thousand hits a day and then 10 000
hits a day then Twenty Thousand Seven
fifty thousand then I got the uh at the
time a big deal the International
Academy of Digital Arts and Sciences had
these awards at the time that were quite
prominent called the Webby Awards now
they're not I don't know if they're
really a thing anymore but at the time I
got the award for best blog I fly down
to New York City I'm walking a red
carpet with like there's selfies of me
there with like Sarah Silverman Martha
Stewart Jimmy Fallon Seth Meyers I go on
stage they have a five word
maximum for speeches the all speeches
have to be five words long so when
Stephen Colbert goes up for his his web
he's like me me me me me me and you know
he walks off it's like a five-word
speech limit so I was like sure
acceptance speeches are awesome and I
walk off if I get this big trophy I come
back 10 literary agents are waiting to
turn my website into a book okay and so
then
um
I signed on with one of these literary
agents Aaron Malone WME she did stuff
like people like which at the time was
the biggest like blog to book out there
and
um she took it to Publishers and she
conducted like at the time like a
bidding war if you could believe it for
this guy's blog to turn into a book and
that turned into the book of awesome
which came out in 2010 and and they
printed 6 000 copies of it no one was
expecting it's just the blog stapled
together into a book it's literally just
the blog in the book you could read the
whole thing for free on the internet
they printed six thousand copies but
there were a number of fortuitous once
again looking backwards things that fell
into place
like Heather reason the CEO and founder
of Indigo books which at the time had
like 70 market share books again made it
a Heather's pick and she typically
picked like literary fiction so it was
very unusual so now the book's at the
front of all the tables then it tips
into like the big media and then I get
invited to do a TED talk and then I'm
invited on The Today Show and on the
early show and all these well they just
create their own spiral yeah the energy
just escalates it's the snowball rolling
downhill exactly at that point it's like
you know everybody want wanted to
feature a book that was about Simple
Pleasures and when you open the book and
you cracked it open the very first
century was flipping to the cold side of
the pillow in the middle of the night
and I just wrote an essay about that
that's it
that's the whole thing
I know but it's kind of amazing right
and like how many how long was this
thing on the on these bestseller lists
like forever yeah it was like it was
years it was yeah hundreds of weeks and
and you do this Ted Talk that goes on to
be like in the top 10 of all time of
tedx is like I don't know five and a
half million views yeah like yeah they
had they had this thing on on their the
10 most inspiring TED talks and it was I
was like number nine or something like
that on that list but when I think about
this
uh what what is most meaningful to me is
that when you started you mentioned like
you started in reverse order so the when
you started the blog the first entry was
number one thousand yeah it wasn't like
number one right so what I infer from
that is you just lower the stakes of the
whole thing there's no pressure it's all
I have to do is come up with a
thousandth kind of awesome thing like so
it doesn't even have to be that awesome
just has to be kind of awesome right and
when you when you lower the pressure
lower the stakes deflate like all of
that like
you know pressure that one can put on
themselves when they're trying to create
something it gives you space and
permission to just be free right back to
like Freedom a lot of your rules are
about like how do you create that place
where you feel safe and free right
um and I know that in my own work like I
have to do that I have to find ways of
doing that for myself because I'll put
oh it has to be perfect has to be like
this I suck I'm terrible
the only way I can kind of
do anything is when I find a way to let
go of all of that and like be like it's
okay like this is your time to suck
you'll edit this a million times before
it goes out like just just be sucky
right now it's cool because everything
I've been able to create has started out
as something terrible and you know
communicating which is what you do uh
you know communicating to people in a
way that that allows them to feel
empowered that allows them to feel like
they too you know can have the capacity
to to express themselves you know in
their own version of of your journey I
think is like a really beautiful thing
thanks yeah yeah it's been it's been a
very it's been a it's been a it's been a
lucky and wild right and beyond anything
that that your rules and your
spreadsheets could predict right this
goes back to like the mystery and the
magic of all of it it's like all I did
was like yeah you know start this blog
and not for nothing and you didn't quit
your job like you were doing this while
you were working like you didn't quit
your job until like way later years
later the whole thing right as you're
having this experience of becoming more
and more uh you know well known for the
creative things that you were sharing
with the world while having this job at
Walmart the whole time I know and it was
really hard to let go of that job
because as we mentioned like a long time
ago it was like the goal was to be a
doctor and if it wasn't going to be a
doctor as an engineer it was a lawyer if
it wasn't going to be engineer it was at
least going to be like an income it was
a salary it was like benefits you know
there's that Naseem Talib quote that the
three most addictive things in life are
sugar heroin and a monthly salary
you know I was like I I was like not
gonna leave that for this what was this
like a book on a bestseller list that
like yeah sure it pays some royalties
today but like that's a 15 minutes of
fame thing that's not gonna last I can't
be a viable career and so for eight
years five books 200 speeches I was at
Walmart the whole time and big Kudos
five books before you left Walmart yeah
I didn't know it was that many yeah yeah
well this is because that's kind of
insane well it's big kudos to the
organization because
um you know uh
I went and spoke to
um you know the head of legal because I
was like I I think I'm like am I
breaking the rules here like I got this
thing on the side I got this blog and
this book and they're they're like
well
um what's it about and I was like uh
well it's about like small Pleasures
like flipping people no well because at
some point like you're on the Today Show
like they're like they know what's going
on yeah yeah they know what's going on
at the same time it was like it I had to
if anything rich I had to like make sure
that I doubled down on on on how I
showed up at work because it would be
too easy for the person that's just not
there on Fridays to be like off on the
TV show so I had to like double down to
work and by the way for four of those
five years I was the project manager the
CEO so for four of those five years I
got a development rotation where I was
working for the CEO and I was two
different CEOs in that role where I'm
like writing CEO speeches I'm like
working on strategy presentations for
the CEO so I like also don't want this
is also a hugely formative development
role for me inside the organization to
see how the leader of the world's
largest company like Works how this how
this office works I'm doing that it's
all also based on communication and and
you know meeting design and doing all
that so I don't also want to let go of
this career you know
I really liked it there and they were
really good to me and I really enjoyed
the company and the culture I have only
positive things to say but it got to the
point where I ha when after I crash
landed downtown I'm Stark single like
I'm like I'm basically like
I'm basically like coming home from work
getting takeout from the the vegetarian
restaurant that's underneath my downtown
Toronto like
um you know bachelor apartment and I'm
sitting at my computer in front of a
glowing screen from 5 P.M to 2 A.M every
single night doing that second entire
job which is right in this blog writing
the books answering media inquiries and
all that stuff so when I show up to the
dating world it's not a pretty scene
like I am showing up to like online
dating sites now like a year into this
after the divorce and I'm like
there's this guy in front of you imagine
he's lost 40 pounds he's real thin he
doesn't know how to talk like I'm like
doing all this stuff online I'm
basically like a a like an internet
hermit you know comment on my shell so
the dates the dating scene for that
first year were just like bad like I
didn't I didn't go on a second date for
over a year and I had a lot of first
dates and I liked a lot of those people
but none of them manifest into anyone
ever giving me the three dots back when
I texted them after the after the after
the day it was like I was ghosted weekly
like I was it just never worked out and
then
finally two years after my divorce I go
on a date with a woman named Leslie
she's a teacher at a Toronto at the
Toronto District School Board and she's
a kindergarten teacher so I'm like
trying to make plans like late at night
she's like I go to bed at eight like
we're gonna have to have like something
early so
um there's a there's a woman on on the
floor that I lived in this bachelor
apartment it was her friend and so we go
we hit it off there is chemistry and I
completely scared I've never told the
story before I completely scare her off
because I flew the next day to go to the
Olympics with the CEO of Walmart's like
cover do some stuff we were doing at the
Olympics and I sent her a text message
that was like
I really like you
I really think this could be a
meaningful long-term relationship I I
would like to date you as soon as I get
back in a week and she's like I am I am
not up for this guy's energy at all yeah
that has nothing to do with like you
know you being a Hermit and writing on
the internet and being too busy that's
just like poor social skills dude thank
you yeah well well it takes six months
but he's such a good talker and you're
so engaging and like charming and and uh
charismatic it's hard for me to imagine
such a such a like a horrific gaff
so we finally get to the second day and
then that we're still on that we're
still on that second date now and now
we've been together are you talking into
a second date after after that text uh
like like bi-weekly text messages for
six months
like like is really chasing chasing
right well that's gets into a whole
other tenet that is a big thing with you
which is like basically like swings at
bat or like you know our relationship to
failure we'll park that for now though
continue yeah yeah well hey the the
pitcher with the most wins Cy Young has
the most losses cyan this pitcher with
the most strike as Nolan Ryan has the
most walks Nolan Ryan so there is
something to just the number of times
you can take a swing so Leslie and I we
hit it off
um on the second day and our hearts
connected you'll be happy to hear and
like I said it feels it feels like that
second date is still is still going now
I'm very very very lucky to be married
to an incredible woman now the thing
about the wedding I don't know if you
knew this
um
she uh uh she basically planned the
whole wedding and so I said I gotta I
want to plan the whole honeymoon like it
was going to be like a surprise
honeymoon and she's like I don't know if
I trust you to plan on the entire
honeymoon but I she did so I the imagine
you're getting married and you don't
know where you're going how long you're
going for nothing it's like this is
going to be the surprise the next day
but I wanted to really plan this
honeymoon because she's basically
playing the wedding so we go to
Southeast Asia neither of us have ever
been before neither of us have been
since but it was like a real a dream
destination and and we go go through
southeast Asia
um
on the flight home she's not feeling
well and we have a six hour layover in
Kuala Lumpur and in that airport which
is like lots of steamy noodles for sale
lots of flashing lights she's very seen
feeling very sick she's looking for a
pharmacy she's looking for a place to
lie down we find her a pharmacy we find
a place to lie down we get on a 13-hour
flight home to Toronto on that airplane
she goes up goes to the bathroom
comes back to our seats like 30 000 feet
above sea level and she looks at me and
she's like I'm pregnant
she bought the pregnancy test from the
pharmacy in the Kuala Lumpur Airport
Pharmacy she did the princess in the
airplane bathroom at the front of the
airplane above the clouds and she tells
me on the flight that she's pregnant so
we land home in Toronto and it's like
our first child was born nine months to
the day after a wedding night wow Mary
July 12th he's born April 12th I spent
that those nine months writing my fifth
and final book while working at Walmart
which was the happiest equation which I
wrote as a 300 Page Letter To My Unborn
Child on how to live a happy life so
that is where that book came from and it
was the one that tipped me over into
eventually trying to figure out do I
want to stay at Walmart or do I wanna
try this writing thing kind of full time
and that question I've been asked many
times how do you make it you're a
systems guy how do you decide whether to
make the leap between organizations
I called the CEO that I was working for
who is a mentor to me Dave cheese Wright
and I said how do I make this decision
he said you only got to ask yourself two
questions and I hold on to these two
questions which whenever I'm trying to
make a major crew decision and I
recommend them for anyone who is
listening to this who's trying to make a
major career decision now the two
questions are number one you got to do
the death bed test and number two you
got to do the plan B test the death bed
test is the simple question you got to
ask yourself which is which of these
choices would I regret not doing more
from the vantage point of my deathbed
okay it sounds simple but when you
really try to internalize and metabolize
it it it it from the heart becomes
clearer which one you naturally would
prefer not to miss out on right and for
me that was like becoming an executive
inside Walmart or trying to get this
writing thing going right the second
thing is the plan B test which is simply
the question is what are you going to do
if this doesn't work out
what's your plan B
and when he asked me that I was like
well I guess I'll have to shine up the
Old Linkedin profile and go knocking
back on the door again and and sort of
uh get back into the corporate world
he's like well do you think you could do
that I was like well now I've been
working here for quite a long time I
probably have a decent chance of getting
some job it's like okay so you've
wrestled with and navigated and and most
importantly visualize what the plan B
looks like for you everyone's degree of
risk is different everyone will have
different levels of comfort with like
how much you're burning the boats and
how much you have something to fall back
on but those two tests the deathbed test
and the plan B test I still use to
illuminate big career decisions yeah
that's that's super interesting and and
helpful to hear and makes a lot of sense
uh on the on the plan B thing
when you were telling that story I'm
thinking about the people uh you know
particularly artists who who uh who will
tell you like there is no plan B like
there's just this is what I'm doing if I
have a plan B that gives me a backdoor
exit out of this thing but I am
committed to making this work I'm in for
the whole shebang and uh you know when
it gets uncomfortable I don't want to be
able to be able to easily bail
like do you like how to burn the boats
yeah yeah and uh the the thing I would
say is that we have a Survivor bias on
those stories where when you typically
hear them from the people that are
successful exactly exactly there's a lot
of and what about the yeah like we live
in Los Angeles every day thousands of
people arrive here pursuing a dream very
few of them actually achieve that dream
and we hear about those amazing Stories
and we don't hear about the people who
end up getting on the bus and going home
that's what I'm saying and so it's just
again everyone's got a different level
of risk if you have there's a lot to be
said like you know you watch that um
Serena and Venus Williams movie it has
the same kind of vibe of like you know
this was the you know remember the press
conference when she's like 13 years old
and she's like I know I'm gonna I know
I'm gonna do this like there's an
undertone of like it's this is success
or bust and I don't personally subscribe
to that as much perhaps because of my
East Indian upbringing and the idea of
having like insurances in place and like
how you're gonna like structure your
life and like so for me thinking about
Plan B and making that at least
palatable if that's how you say the word
enough so that you know if it fails you
have something to come back on is a
little bit more my brain yeah sure lower
risk again it's all about like what is
your like getting really connected to
what your risk tolerance is exactly
exactly
um I want to shift gears a little bit
and pivot more into this whole world of
Happiness a lot of conversation around
happiness how do we get it how do we
cultivate it where are we thinking about
this correctly incorrectly
um pursuing the Art and Science Of
Happiness now has become like a career
path for many people yeah many
interesting thought leaders I'm thinking
of Arthur Brooks and many others you're
certainly one of those people you wrote
this amazing book the happiness equation
and you have some interesting thoughts
around
uh how we think about practice and try
to cultivate happiness into our lives
you're here in part in Los Angeles
because you're going to go give a
keynote at Expo West and I think that
the nature of that keynote is around
happiness right and yeah how we're
thinking around about it incorrectly so
I don't know State your thesis around
that this like where are we going wrong
with with uh you know our Pursuit of
Happiness sure so just zooming out like
a huge level before we get into like my
My Views let's just remember that 2400
years ago in ancient Athens Aristotle at
the world's first University Plato's
Republic had a very famous quote
happiness is the meaning and purpose of
life the whole aim and end of human
existence that if you want to talk about
people that have made a career out of
happiness or you know that there's the
OG guys the original happiness
influencer well before that it was like
survival like we got it we just gotta
make it through this thing you know like
we he's like no no no no no no no the
whole purpose is also we got to enjoy it
too 2400 years ago oh he they put that
down right then Flash Forward 2000 years
they write the Declaration of
Independence you know the famous phrase
they put in there everybody gets life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness but
you're a lawyer Rich you know it's the
legalese in there you don't get
happiness you get to pursue it you get
to pursue it you get the pursuit of it
life liberty you get those for sure
about happiness you just get to chase it
right
so now we Flash Forward all the way up
to 1998 let's say Martin Seligman and
mihal chicken are co-founders of a new a
new field that they they invent called
positive psychology right and for a lot
of your listeners who have heard that
phrase before pause this psychology it's
we should remember it that phrase didn't
exist in our culture before 25 years ago
so that's still a relatively new phrase
so from 1998 to today hundreds and
hundreds of Studies have been done
applying the scientific model to the
study of Happiness right Carol dweck on
growth mindset slasher and Panabaker on
on journaling Evans and McCullough on
gratitude at University of California
there's these there's these there's this
massive huge emerging body of work and
literature so I just use those three
points to just say like just just look
what's happened here like 2000 we say
this is important then we write it into
the the Declaration we got to chase it
and now we're like starting to actually
study it only really 25 years ago
now
I think that the underpinning of how we
think about happiness in our society is
totally backwards okay we when I was a
kid what my parents said to me was we've
already talked about this a few times
but it's like come on you know study
hard you know get get straight A's and
you go be a doctor the model therefore
is great work
leads to big success leads to be happy
right and that model is also if you're
listening to this and you're a parent
it's like don't you say to your own come
on we want you to get into a good school
come on we want you to get a good job
come on we just want you to be that's
common parental wisdom and it's totally
false so after combing through all these
studies there's a really formative study
done by sayula bemirski with Ed Diener
and King Jin King
and they show that actually that model
is totally backwards it's not great work
big success be happy it's the opposite
it's you got to train your brain to be
happy first
then if you can do that if you can think
of Happiness like a practice like a
habit like something you can invest in
you invest in your physical health so
beautifully we see that we aspire to it
we see that you're a model but how many
people do you look around and you see
them investing in their happiness the
same way we don't we aren't as a culture
doing this yet then the great work
follows happy people are 31 more
productive they have 37 higher sales
they're 300 more crave you can go down
the Litany of all kinds of things that
happy people show up better they're more
connected and then the big success comes
at the end what kind of success two
kinds if you want to go on the career
point which I was on for a second there
happy people are 40 more likely to get a
promotion in the next 12 months but just
zooming up a level there's this really
famous study called the nun study that
shows you know what happy people also
also live live longer and if going back
to our earlier conversation you only got
30 000 days here well if I told you if
you you could get 3 000 more
bowls of ice cream kissing your kids
good night watching the sunset running
on the trails behind this place once you
do it so again it's not great work big
success be happy it's the reverse you've
got to train and prime your brain to
think of Happiness like a practice like
a habit like something you invest in
then being happy leads to doing great
work and the great work leads to having
big success
I'm with you man I mean that notion that
false notion is so deeply embedded into
my DNA and the only way that I got to a
place of of deconstructing it and trying
to rewire that was through like personal
crisis right it's like I chased that
exactly like you yeah
um well-intentioned parents who were
like we just want you to be we want you
to be happy like we want you to be like
we just want you to be happy but
implicit in that is like yeah but
happiness is a product of like you do
all these things and you go you you have
this career and you do all this and and
the result the implied result of all of
this effort all of this endeavor is the
happiness and it is backwards right like
it is a choice happiness is a verb it's
a practice like gratitude like presence
like mindfulness
um and yet you are so correct like there
is no priority
around
this notion let alone some shared idea
of what those practices are to cultivate
it right well and and and and on top of
all that a lot of the practice that
turns out that do help you cultivate
happiness have got real bad ad campaigns
they don't have uh the benefit of anyone
advertising trees no one's advertising
trees right now well because you can't
profit from it that's exactly what I'm
saying yeah that's exactly what I'm
saying the vast majority of things that
I'm about to tell you about that can
actually imbue Our Lives is a bit more
happiness they don't have great Giant ad
campaigns and we aren't talking about
them in a in the the
what our culture is trying to teach us
is that you gotta buy more stuff you got
to click more links you got to buy more
things and that path to happiness is you
know whatever is on a billboard that
looks that looks pretty that you know
someone smiling the implicit thing is
that that's going to lead to happiness
it's not well and it's so powerful such
that somebody could listen to you and
say Neil is spot on I totally get that
he's he's 100 right money doesn't buy
happiness but then in the back of your
mind you're like yeah but you know
just if I could I'm going to get that
job yeah and then I'm going to get that
other that new condo yeah I can like
upgrade my Carly sure then everything's
gonna be good like I somehow we still
think that that we are exceptions to
that well that notion and I say about
money in particular because people do
ask me all the time does money buy
happies and I do say yes and here's what
I say about it there's a really famous
study done by Daniel Kahneman at the
Woodruff School in Princeton that shows
that above a certain level of Baseline
income at the time of the study it was
done it was like 75 000 which was by the
way is way above you know average
household income so it's pretty high
amount then your happiness diminishes
after that if you put it into today's
money it might be ninety thousand or a
hundred thousand or something like that
meeting your needs and having some uh
percentage of disposable income to
pursue the things that make you happy
exactly now using the research that is
many research studies have been done
since I say money does buy happies if
you buy the three s's okay the three S's
are sweat
skill
and social
okay if you use your money to buy those
three things and actually buy it
actually buys happiness so let me take
you through each one sweat I suck at
baseball I'm on a softball team I'm
honest I'm honestly I'm running around
I'm not the kind of I can't run like you
rich I'm not a runner I'm not a do an
exercise that doesn't go I can play
sports so buying this 200 ticket every
summer to join the softball team is like
a guaranteed Sunday night sweat that is
really good for my happiness levels
absolutely I almost feel great at the
end of it and there's a lot of research
to support this then skill we are
learning animals where's this podcast
classified is it education self-help
well all the categories on Apple or
whatever they're all about self-help we
are we are learning animals We crave
learning we want to learn so if you can
invest in a skill okay I think this is
behind the whole like Master Class
phenomenon if you can invest in taking
something you've never taken before you
can take a painting class if you you
could take a language course if you
could you know if you could buy the
experience of learning something new
that's also going to pay off in your
happiness levels and the third and final
one is probably the biggest which is
social so the 1938 however adult
development study longest running study
on happiness over time shows that
community and connection is one of the
biggest drivers ever happiness if you
take the form of 2006 book stumbling on
happiness by Daniel Gilbert at Harvard
he has a phrase in there that says if I
can know everything there was to know
about you
your health your gender your income your
nationality all of it would fall away in
favor of the strength of your
relationships with your friends and
family so what does spending money on
social actually turn out to be well it's
like going up it's going out for dinner
it's going out for dinner it's it's it's
it's leaning into saying yes when the
social opportunities that cost money are
you know encountered by you and that
adage I know I know it's simple I know
it's a Zinger but but but it adds up to
a little model that I use when it comes
to that specific kind of sub question we
were just starting to explore on does
money buy happiness I think it does if
you buy sweat skill or social
experiences but those three s's don't
necessarily have to be bought they can
be cultivated they're not necessarily
absolutely financially you know like
things that cost money like you can
cultivate community and friendships you
know outside of that on on some level
and you can sweat without having to you
know pay a bunch of money all of those
things are available the that vast
majority of things that lead to our
happiness are are afraid to your point I
was just you know just going down that
path of money specifically but like
zooming up a level look
ah
you're a paragon of this rich but like
like just getting outside and being in
nature and by the way I'll just preface
this point uh by saying we we have the
lowest ever levels of nature exposure in
our children in history according to the
American time you study seven percent of
a kid's day right now is spent outside
seven percent we'll do the math multiply
seven percent by seven days in a week
that's 49 it takes a kid a whole week to
get half a day outside now right so
what's the solution Michael babick and a
team of researchers have shown that even
three 30-minute exercise or outdoor
Windows a week
ultimately results in higher happiness
levels than people taking
antidepressants or people doing both
they compared it to a subgroup doing
both the walking and taking the
antidepressants so this this I said
trees have a bad ad campaign it's like
we're missing the amount that we really
need to be outside and one of the
biggest ways I tell people to do this is
if you have a meeting on your calendar
with someone you know that you like
already that you trust already whether
it's your boss whether it's your direct
report whether it's a weekly meeting
that you always have just say to the
person let's both do it outside let's
just both do it outside the average
person walks this kilometers an hour you
move one hour meeting a week outside you
get 6K of walking move two you got 12.
move three you got 18. it's a simple way
to just introduce a little bit more
outdoor activity in your life it doesn't
cost anything and it has a huge positive
disproportionate effect on your
happiness
it's hard not to see the the kind of
tragic aspect of this because on some
level we're all victims of modern
progress and technological Evolution
because it wasn't that many decades ago
that Society was constructed in such a
way where it was conducive to these
three s's just by living your life you
would be you know kind of engaged with
those in a very fundamental way without
even trying and now we have to you know
erect all of these systems and create
boundaries and you know and set
intentions just to do things that were
kind of naturally wired to do I know uh
and and short of the way that we've
decided to live our lives we would
ordinarily but you know as a result of
of you know kind of urbanization
Etc which has been exacerbated by covet
and all of that were really separated
from Community we're disconnected we're
living Our Lives more and more digitally
we're not going Outdoors uh you know the
skills that we're developing are all
digital skills
they're not they're not like tactile
skills in in the way that we've
traditionally thought about them and
these are distancing ourselves from our
ability to connect with happiness and
then of course there's the conversation
around the relationship between
happiness and and Longevity it's like if
you're you know if you're not sweating
and you're not learning new skills and
kind of like actively engaging your mind
and you're not connected to your
community you ain't gonna live that long
right right so you're going to be
unhappy and die early
yeah and it's true we have so much of
what is designed in the world today is
like the default settings do not
naturally allow for us to succeed on our
happiness level I mean when I got the
new iPhone and the first thing I saw
when I opened the screen is like it just
bombards you with the news I was like oh
my gosh they set this thing up so that
you now have to like figure out how to
like edit the widget delete them all I
have to clean up my dock otherwise it's
full of all these notifications I have
to delete all social it's like you gotta
work really hard to create a space where
it allows happiness to kind of come into
the picture and that's just on one thing
that we're talking about on exercise
here's another one that I I just want to
give a little quick rant on here it's
reading fiction from a real book we are
losing and I know you've had a great
interview with Johann Hari on on the
show
guys have you just had him on I did just
he just went up like this week on your
show right I just did yeah he's uh he's
he's uh I got into chasing the scream
and it was it was it was really
wonderful and um you know uh we're
losing our capacity to read and it's oh
it's horrifying what's happening so 57
of Americans read zero books last year
zero not one that's the first time it's
been in the majority okay and why is
this an issue well according to the 2011
annual review of psychology only reading
fiction opens up the mirror neurons in
our brain responsible for empathy
compassion and understanding
my job when I was at Walmart was to help
grow leaders managers and directors
directors of eps VPC seps you know what
the number one Gap was amongst all
leaders at all levels like what's the
derailleur what's going to take you off
course
EQ
empathy compassion understand Tony
you're awesome at your job Tony no one
likes in the meeting Tony is not going
to get promoted and you can't ship that
person off to empathy class it doesn't
exist reading actually immersing your
mind in another life is one of the very
few ways that we can actually grow our
empathy our compassion understanding
these are
very incalculable skills that are
important for a trust-based cohesive
Society to exist right you have you have
to there's that George RR Martin quote
our reader lives A Thousand Lives before
he dies the man who never reads lives
only one
and we're losing our capacity to engage
with books we're losing our ability to
fall into other lives and less able to
identify and relate to the people around
us massive issue so I am very bullish on
books you know this about me yeah I am
obsessed with reading books I think it's
very important and I have we have books
all over our house we have books in
every room of our house we are trying to
surround our children's lives with books
I think it's I think we're losing our
capacity to read books and scares me so
much so that I just yelled about it for
a couple minutes yeah and and I'm
sitting here feeling guilty like I do
read a lot but all of my reading is
non-fiction and is driven by guests that
I host on the podcast yeah that
monopolizes all of my I couldn't tell
you the last time I read a fiction book
I see lots of movies maybe that serves
some it does a piece of that but it's
not the same thing and I would say that
you know as a parent of of older
children
it's it's been like the older the two
older boys voracious readers especially
Juan Trapper just like incredible reader
the younger ones it's hard man yeah you
know you're competing against uh you
know inputs that are so addictive and
you're trying to tell that child like
hey you should read a book it's like
they're like they're looking at you like
you're a martian like what are you
talking about I know I loved your
conversation with Casey neistat and he
said you know comparing Tick Tock to
reading a book is like comparing like
it's like eating like a kale sandwich or
it's like it's so difficult to try to
wrestle with a book after being do you
want to walk on hot coals or ride in a
spaceship that's what I'm saying yeah
it's it's very very difficult that
doesn't mean it's impossible and the way
I encourage people to do it or to get
back into it is I say first off we got
to start with moving the cell phones out
of the bedroom we have to start with
that right now if I go in front of an
audience and I say put your hand up if
you sleep within five feet of your cell
phone guess that's what 98 99 of hands
are up in the air okay
and I say what'd you do before bed
people are like well I checked I checked
my cell phone I gotta see if my boss
texted me I gotta check the markets I
gotta see what's going on Twitter
somebody comment on my Instagram post
what'd you do when you woke up in the
morning it's back to two minute mornings
again you know I checked myself was the
first thing it's the first thing we do
it's the last thing we do we're sleeping
beside the thing and it's the first
thing we do I say listen everybody stop
if you drank up all the wine before bed
every night slept within five feet of a
ball of wine and drank a bottle of wine
when you woke up every morning we'd have
no problem calling an alcoholic we are
phonaholics now and when everyone has an
addiction it looks like no one has this
addiction it is a problem it's a huge
problem and we gotta get the phones out
of the bedroom
you know what the number one excuse is I
hear when people say that they say oh
well it's my alarm clock
go to Walmart it's ten dollars you can't
like buy an alarm clock as permission to
get the phone out of the bedroom oh well
I'm very very important I get lots of
calls a night no you don't you really
don't and if you think you do give get a
get a landline and give it to the three
people that you think might call you and
guess what the permission of thinking oh
my mom my my sick sister and my my boss
that they could call me that gives you
permission to get the phone out of the
bedroom why is that important because
when you have the phone out of the
bedroom Rich you make space in the
morning to do two minute mornings and
you make space before you go to bed to
read and this is what I say to people
two pages of fiction before bed I say
two specifically I don't say read a book
I don't say read 20 pages I don't say
read 20 minutes I used to say read 20
minutes and no one did it now I've got a
new thing and it's really working read
two pages of fiction before bed as the
last thing you do and you know what
animal farm is 96 pages
so you know in a couple months you're
ahead of the whole world because 57 of
people are reading nothing so just
getting back into the idea of reading a
couple Pages before bed at the end of
the night is a way to start back on the
trail and I think we can I think we can
do it I know that the we know how good
it feels how good does it feel when you
finish a a piece of food it feels good
and also for people that struggle with
sleep or insomnia uh pick up a book and
like read it start reading a book before
you go to bed yeah you're out exactly no
like you will like fall asleep and then
beyond that I saw really sorry but I
thought it was like really funny it's
like a post on Instagram or Twitter
um but it was like oh yeah people you
know talk [__] about reading books but
if you think about it you're literally
like taking a tree and then you know
like and then staring at pieces of a
tree and hallucinating is there anything
crazier than that [__] exactly exactly
some trippy [__] right it's very trippy
I I think you're a fan of on writing by
Stephen King right where he calls you
know that on writing by Stephen King he
calls he calls uh reading
um you know telekinesis or he calls it
um ESP like he's like basically what you
do when you're reading is you're totally
transported into another mind probably
getting the word wrong but it's the it's
the concept of yeah it's real right it's
it's the most ai ai we have
you know you're engaging an aspect of
your brain to you know like like connect
with imagination in a way that like
watching a movie or TV show it's not
just us saying it here they've done MRI
scans at Emory University even the
morning after people read literary
fiction and guess what more of their
brain is opened up and being used even
the smell centers even the language
centers if you read the word soap and
you read the word leather and you read
the word cinnamon your smell centers are
opening up and when you watch the movie
I'm not I'm not crapping on movies here
but you're not you know someone else is
the director you watch big little lies
they chose the actresses they want Reese
Witherspoon to wear this they want
Nicole Kim to wear that they choose this
nice fancy bathroom this is the way this
is the music's Gonna Roll this is the
they're the directors when you read the
book you are you have to use more of
your brain and it feels good to use it
it feels so good it really does it makes
you happier it really does there's a
famous article in the New Yorker called
does reading make you happier guess what
the answer is yes
hahaha
I'm thinking like this is going to make
for a really good reel on Instagram like
what you just said the case for reading
books
um
another uh you know tenet in your in
your happiness equation is this idea
that that nobody should retire and so
you have these interesting ideas around
the nature of retirement and how this
idea of retirement like became a thing
yeah this is remember I said that the uh
the the dollar uh the the comparing
salaries on dollar per hour was was like
one of my most controversial the never
retire is probably the most
controversial chapter I've written in
any of my books and so basically here's
the deal
um
in
1889 in Germany Chancellor Otto von
Bismarck coolest Head of State name of
all time Chancellor Otto von Bismarck he
had a problem you know those problems
Rich he had youth unemployment in like
the 20s and 30s percentage and so he
decreed from the state that anybody
65 and older
could make a claim to the state and get
a little bit of money to bridge them
from age 65 to death this is where the
concept of retirement was invented okay
late 1800s in Germany why is it notable
couple things average lifespan was 67.
so the guy's only providing a little
bridge to two years really they didn't
invent penicillin for 40 more years okay
so like we was we weren't living nearly
as long but what happened was we ended
up using this number 65 Across the
Western world as like oh let's just cut
let's just copy that if you look at the
the UK the U.S Social Security Act the
Canadian act 65 became this arbitrary
retirement age
well if you look through at the 20th
century
the percentage of people over 65 that
chose to retire after age 65 was
extremely low because people thought
correctly that it was against activity
Theory the idea that like no we want
people to like be a big part of society
in 1951 the Corning Corporation began an
ad Campaign together with insurance
companies to Bill retirement is
something that you deserve for years of
work and to Market like relaxing as this
like new concept that was like behind
the whole idea of building that
retirement communities out in like
Florida and Arizona and so on
the percentage of people that chose kind
of living a life of pleasure after 65
from that point onwards skyrocketed
through the decades to the point where
now we've got life spans that are way
longer you take that 37 30 000 days you
distill this 83 but you know a lot of
people are living to the 80s to their
90s and there's actually downward
pressure on the retirement age the
downward pressure on the retirement is
you know in Canada I grew up it's like
Freedom 55 like you want to get off work
as soon as possible
and what we're doing
is we're killing ourselves we really are
Fortune Magazine says the two most
dangerous years of your lives are the
year you're born and the year you retire
there's a reason that almost everybody I
know
probably including you definitely
including me has a story of someone who
retired and then they
lights out my guidance counselor in high
school was forced out of work at age 65
because that was this right that was the
mandatory retirement and he had a heart
attack and he died the next week and a
lot of people have stories like that so
I say it's not that we want to retire
you don't want to do nothing what we
want to do is find something we love and
so what I actually say to people is
okay you're looking for the four s's
that's what you're looking for I know
that these are different than the three
s's I just talked about on on money
they're they are social okay that's the
overlapping one structure stimulation
and story
it doesn't matter if you get paid I
didn't say one of those s's a salary
what I'm saying is that what we're
looking for in life is something that
gives us the social connection of being
part of a community or a group right the
structure of getting out of bed in the
morning and having an icky guy okay icky
guy that word you've had Dan button
around a number of times from the blue
zones yeah Okinawan word they don't have
a word for retirement in in the language
there they have a word called ikigai
ikigai which means the reason you gotta
bed in the morning structure stimulation
we've already talked about it we're
learning animals we want to be learning
something new every day and Story the
ability to be part of something bigger
than yourself
okay these are four natural Cravings we
have so that's not assess our desire to
retire by a certain age and do quote
unquote nothing you know to pursue a
life of leisure for what it's going to
be like an internal set of decades a we
can't afford it the average the average
we're way underwater on the financial
side of this thing we can't afford to
help other to pay for it to be happening
in the state there's all kinds of
countries around the world that are like
not going to be able to pay for the
people that are about to retire from the
number of people that are below them you
know what I mean the demographic curves
don't work very well and it's a New
Concept that was just invented over a
hundred years ago in the western world
like it doesn't exist in a lot of places
so I say retirement is a bunk concept we
should not desire to retire instead we
should crave the four S's and we should
seek those to the end of our days and
seek those through some kind of of of
profession that will compensate us for
pursuing them like I'm trying to parse
that notion which I agree with with this
notion of you know pursue what you love
yeah you know and then I'm also thinking
in the back of my mind like is
retirement even a thing anymore like
Millennials don't think about it like
like retirement is is this is relic of
like our parents generation on some
level like it was all about like you get
the job you work there for 30 years or
whatever and then you get your
retirement but we're in this kind of
digital Nomad you know dispersed
workplace kind of economy now right
where it's more Project based and there
isn't a transactional cost from kind of
switching jobs like there used to be
right like it's very different so I
think how we're thinking about
retirement is different and perhaps
healthier and we're younger yet so we're
not even you know these people are not
even at the age where that becomes you
know tested but um I agree with you like
this idea like you've worked the job
forever and now you're going to buy a
boat and go fishing like yeah like we
have enough evidence to suggest that
that's not the recipe well you do and
you're on you're on board but it's still
it's still I don't I don't think we're
as far along culturally as you as as you
said I think we still have the idea of
that yeah there is a retirement age and
I'll get there and I'll I'll have saved
up enough that I will therefore be able
to do whatever I want forever after that
but what I'm saying is that what we lose
there in terms of social Connection in
terms of stimulation in terms of like
having a sense of purpose is actually
we're losing a lot more than just just
the money side of it so I'm saying if
you if you it's really freeing I find
it's another cyst it's a really really
freeing I find to think of myself I'm
43. I'm never I'm never gonna retire I
find that quite liberating but you don't
work for Walmart anymore and you're a
writer and you're kind of you know
you're dictating the course of your
career in a similar way that I am and
these are very privileged positions
there's a lot of people who are in you
know kind of gigs where they don't have
that kind of agency in autonomy and
perhaps their pension or 401k or
whatever it is isn't even going to be
adequate to kind of create that that
retirement experience that you know was
something that was achievable 30 40 50
years ago like yeah the economy has
changed as well like so yeah I'm not
saying finished 30 years of the meat
packing plan punch in for 30 more right
I'm saying just keep chasing the
variables that we know actually make you
happy as opposed to so some if somebody
is in that type of of professional
environment and is like look I'm just
you know I work all day long and I
contribute to my 401k and maybe my my
employer you know matches that or
whatever and at some point you know I am
thinking about retirement but that's 20
years away or 10 years away like what
should I be doing now what should I be
thinking about so that I don't become a
casualty of what you've just right
explain well the way I would suggest to
those people to think about it and I
think you know and and I think that's a
really fair point and I want to just
expand on a little bit it's like think
about the number of hours in a week
think about that number it's a 168. you
divide that number by three it's three
buckets of 56. if you sleep eight hours
a night it's 56 hours a week okay if you
happen to be working at the meat packing
plant for 30 years maybe you're working
56 hours maybe working a little bit less
maybe working up to 56 call the second
bucket now let's think about that third
bucket and the whole time that you're
designing yourself towards that pension
that exit that last day that that party
with the gold watch let's just cultivate
that third bucket see my mom when she
retired from her government job she was
working at GM as an account and then she
went to go work for the Ministry of
Finance she retired my dad was still
working me and my sister out of the
house and she ended up in the swirl of
not having the social structure the
stimulation the story and that created
its own negative problems so I'm saying
this take that third bucket of time
let's in let's enliven it grow plant
seeds
volunteering at the library starting to
do something in your community do it
taking care of a grandchild a lot of
people is like taking care of a great
grandkid create and cultivate that third
bucket so that when you retire from that
job that is paying you money you have
the four s's in another way really what
I'm advocating for is not to not to is
to retire the idea of doing nothing
that's what I'm really against yeah it's
it's
putting in the the the lattice work or
the structure in your life today and
continuously so that through your life
till your very last day you are enriched
and fulfilled through doing meaningful
work and also on top of that we need it
we need it look at the world we need it
we want we want your we want input we
want your artistic Creations we want
your energy we want your child care we
want your connection we need it we need
it and what about your wisdom how about
valuing uh the wisdom of you know the
our elders you know people who reach
that retirement age who have so much
lived experience and our culture kind of
you know discards them as opposed to
valuing them yeah I think as a society
we need to find better ways of of you
know creating situations in which you
know people who are on that cusp of
retirement can plug into meaningful ways
of of contributing back what they've
learned for you know the younger
generation 100 you mentioned Arthur
Brooks earlier I love his Concept in
that in his book from strength to
strength of going from Dynamic
intelligence to crystallized
intelligence and the idea of learning
and leaning into roles where Mastery and
wisdom can be communicated I will say
yeah you know when I started at Walmart
there was a lot of people with badges
that they turned gold and color they
were like you know the 30-year badge the
40-year badge even sometimes a 50 a
50-year badge it tells you a lot about
the culture of an organization on how
they value their most senior employees
as I continue over there over over the
um 10 years that I worked there
they started to prioritize
the simpler and easier metrics the
metrics like productivity right and
those metrics tend to lend themselves
towards younger workers I love it when I
walk through a Costco and the badges now
say since and the date is the year that
they started and you walk through a
Costco it's like since 1997 since 1994
since 2001. this is an organization that
values and prioritizes education and
wisdom to the point where they're
bragging about it on their badge because
they know that there's an incalculable
amount of human knowledge and wisdom
that can be passed and traded that isn't
just measured in like the number of
widgets you can push through the machine
per hour it is measured in the idea that
you know what to do not how to do it
faster and I completely agree with you
about the fact that we are generally in
society discounting wisdom and
intelligence especially amongst older
people it's a huge issue massive issue
and so for anyone listening to this as
part of an organization figure out how
you value prioritize and broadcast
experience internally and do so in a
healthy way
there's not enough
there's not enough organizations that
are truly valuing mentorship at that
level yeah yeah I agree and then
shifting gears like that's really solid
advice for people that are in the you
know kind of Twilight of their
professional careers but
um what is where is your head and and
what kind of advice do you give younger
people who are embarking you know on at
the the beginning of their career right
somebody who's looking to enter the you
know professional Marketplace or
creators people who are aspiring writers
bloggers
Etc or Executives yeah you used a phrase
maybe 10 or 15 minutes ago Rich that was
I thought interesting or you said
um you know do what you love I just I
just heard that phrase come out 10 or 15
minutes ago and that phrase do what you
love is probably the most common phrase
I would argue in in commencement
speeches right to pursue your past to do
what you love and I think that that that
phrase in commencement speeches is
totally wrong I think the phrase should
actually be amended extended to do you
love it so much you can take the pain
and the punishment too
there's a wonderful anecdote that Mark
Manson tells author of The subtle art
not giving a [__] ratchet he didn't want
to be a writer he wanted to be a rock
star yeah he actually wanted to be a
rock star but the idea of lugging amps
to smoking nightclubs every Tuesday
he couldn't do that and practicing the
same like chord progression like for
eight hours he's like I'm not into that
but the pain and punishment that goes to
becoming a great writer I.E sending out
like giant responses to Facebook
comments and until like three of them he
loved that and that was the pain and
Punishment required to get to the job of
being a great writer which which he
absolutely is and so what am I saying is
for the younger people they're thinking
about what to do the question you should
ask Jeff isn't do what is it what I love
it's do I love it so much that I can
take the long hard road to getting to
the point of success meaning do you
enjoy the inevitable and necessary hard
years and hard times that go if someone
was listening to this right now saying I
love lugging amps to to smoking clubs
and Tuesday nights and I'm really into
practicing chord progressions well there
you go you might be the rock star you
might be the rock star but finding out
what pain you like to go with the thing
that you're Desiring is equally
important what's your preferred mode of
suffering
there you go right like what are you
willing to suffer for
um yeah I like that I like that lens on
that so
my mind turns to the young person who
who is like yeah but I just don't even I
don't I don't have enough life
experience yet to even know how to
answer that question well and this is
where I get back to I do a lot of things
in in 10 decade increments because if
you're born today your lifespan is over
100. so if you're born today your
lifespan is over a hundred okay
so if you're listing this right now it's
just a fun number to play with to think
of the idea that you know knock on wood
and barring any sort of you know
unforeseen terminal illness or crazy
accent let's just think about your life
in terms of decades let's think of in
terms of 10 decades just as a rubric
here for a second hold on with me here
you might say I'm not gonna live to 100
just just hang on for a second
I like thinking about that because it
relieves me from the obligation of
trying to figure out what I need to do
today or even this week or even this
year in favor of a more decade by decade
like planful
schedule that's why I keep 10 rocks on
my dresser beside my bed and I have four
of those rocks I'm 43 moved forward and
I have six of those rocks moved
backwards I move one rock forward Rich
every 10 years okay why because no
matter what ales or stresses or issues I
had the day it falls away in the face of
this rock clock I got the idea from the
Jeff Bezos like rock clock that they're
putting in like some rock face you know
it's gonna dong every ten thousand years
you know that whole thing the ten
thousand yeah I read something well
there's something about the idea of
conceptualizing time on its longest
length that allows you on a more minute
by new basis how we live to not feel as
worried about it because hey it's just
one moment in a 10-year span why is this
important because you mentioned you know
younger people who maybe at the
beginnings of their career who maybe not
know what they're going to do who don't
know what they love and I say
there's a decade for that it's called
your 20s okay the first two decades are
pretty much for almost everybody pure
learning decades you're pretty much
learning from zero to five you're
learning at home
gotta flush the toilet look hopefully
before across the street like you know
how to pull up your pants then from five
into you know how long can you stay
you're in the the industrial design
educational system uh uh adding in your
own Creations on top of it but you're
learning and I will say yes we yes a lot
of the sort of natural tendencies of if
humans are delayed so like people are
getting married later they're having
kids later Etc but eventually if that
continues to happen for this population
in the face of AI and everything else
it's probably going to happen in your
30s and Beyond okay so then you got one
beautiful juicy right perfect decade in
the middle your 20s that Third Rock
where it is truly I believe
about experimentation
it's about trying The Quiznos Sub Shop
that makes no money it's about going
down to New York and living in a in a in
a bombers apartment and taking an F
train in a different city and I'm not
saying I did that in with the foresight
that I now I'm describing it with I'm
just saying looking back well what a
great way to spend the decade trying a
whole bunch of different things trying a
job in an office trying relationships
trying on different identities trying
different communities trying different
cultures trying different countries that
you might want to live in your 20s are a
decade to play with all the malleable
structure in your life and the byproduct
of that is massive amounts of learning
massive amounts of learning you've had
they have an Epstein on talking about
range had Andrew huberman on talking
about his you know a remarkable path to
becoming where he is now a human lab
guess what they have in common
wild and totally unpredictable path that
ultimately result in a gelling of life's
wisdom and and learnings that form a
person's identity and help them figure
out what they want to do and that decade
did specifically your 20s it's like
beautiful I love it like yeah you're
speaking my love language your 20s are
for experimentation it's interesting
because when you are in that age group
you think everything is so Mission
critical and so it's hard to like
inhabit that sensibility that this is
the time for trying a million different
things and not really worrying about it
but it is that decade where you don't
have a lot of responsibilities you don't
have kids you're probably not married
like Live Lean and whatever kind of you
know way that you're making money like
try to spend it on experiences and
broadening yourself and lower the bar
and try all different kinds of things
because this is the years where you're
figuring it out right and you should
embrace that so so I had Rayne Wilson on
the podcast yeah and he went on a jaunt
about like your 20s and we made a real
out of that and that is like the most
viral thing that I that we've ever share
I don't know I don't know how many
millions of people like watched that and
it was controversial too and the people
who don't like it tend to be the people
in their 20s who are like you don't
understand yeah I have it harder than
you might imagine yeah and I'm
sympathetic to that but also that that
is proving my point that when you are in
your 20s sometimes you can't see uh you
know that for what it's worth it's not
until you're older and you reflect back
and you're like oh yeah your 20s that's
when you're supposed to do all this
stuff and like not worry about it yeah
and and if you if you're listening to
this and you're thinking well you don't
understand I'm under a mountain of law
school debt and I really right yeah I
get it and things will become more
difficult when and if you have a
mortgage and children and and things
that are like you know implanted into
it'll become
yourself of the opportunity to go on
that exploration to really figure out
what it is that you want to do and be
and you're just delaying the existential
crisis that will visit you you know when
you're 39 if you're like me right or
whenever it is like if you're repressing
it and just being like well I'm paying
the bills and I got to do this thing
like you know nothing goes away like
whatever it is that you're running from
or or or trying to hide from or
pretending doesn't exist will resurface
and it will you know it will come back
stronger than it than it is when it's in
your 20s at a low boil right and you
have the opportunity to kind of like
explore and and and deal with those
things absolutely I love countries that
have institutionalized the concept of
Gap years right you know we don't have
that really in Canada I don't think in
the U.S definitely not definitely not
right but when you hear about
Australians and Brits
yeah that's a great
structural
you know and and it's aligned with what
we're saying from a structural level so
well the real insanity is that we're
supposed to know when we're 18 years old
what we want to do with our lives
exactly I don't know who came up with
that you're talking about yeah Bismarck
and like coming up with a retirement age
yeah but who decided that you know
between 18 and 21 you got to sort it out
and know exactly who you want to be you
know in a professional capacity in the
world like that's just completely insane
I know and unfortunately the pressure on
young people I know when they don't know
they feel bad about themselves like it's
just this is like really pernicious I
know and it's getting worse because the
there's the quote unquote death of
liberal arts education right like
there's the increased pressure to
specialize so that you can produce and
have an income at a younger and younger
age to sort of pay for the lifestyle
that we think we all need
it's rough man all right I want to
switch gears a little bit and talk about
uh talk about balance like when I think
about you and your life like you have
four young boys yeah but you've written
all these books and you travel and you
speak you're incredibly productive
you're able to you know be a good dad
and be a president partner to your wife
and everything seems to be like in check
right so when it's not as simple yeah
sure on a day-to-day basis it's not like
I'm projecting of course
um but how do you think about like
balance oh live a balanced life
everything should be in balance and how
do you practice this notion how do you
challenge traditional Notions around
like living a balanced life like talk
about that a little sure three things
I'll say the last thing I took a
marriage course before we got married
okay we had a non-denominational uh
ceremony and the woman who married us
said I would just like to practice my
new course with you I usually am going
to charge 500 but would you mind just
meeting with me for eight Saturdays in a
row and I'm gonna take you through this
like curriculum that I've developed on
like pre-practicing for marriage and one
of the exercises that she gave us which
I recommend people do before they're
married is
and there's a lot of good things that
came out of this little little course
that I still think about today one of
them was she said once we got through
the conversation of whether we wanted to
have children okay that was an important
part of the pre-marriage course because
that was not to be determined after the
marriage but before she then said write
down on the piece of paper the
percentage of the child care that you
believe you will do and then on the
count of three flip over your papers and
when we flipped over the papers I had
written down 25 percent unless they had
written down 75 okay so I will say it's
going to get me in trouble it's just
because let's just be really clear that
a big part of all the stuff you're
talking about is I'm doing about 25 of
the parenting that's because Leslie is
the one on call
with all the kids during the day
especially as we've had babies at home
pretty much the whole time and in the
evenings
um she'll she'll pick them up she'll
pick them up from school I will re-enter
The Fray around 4 pm every single day
and then we're tag teaming it together
from then until bedtime but make no
mistake who's picking out whether
someone needs shoes figuring out the
lunches like figuring out the quick it's
she's doing 75 so that's one thing I'll
say on battle on balance is that you
have to decide up front how that is
going to work for you and every single
couple or every single person is
listening we'll have a different way of
doing it you know Leslie and I have
friends were like
the woman says I'm good with my husband
just doing the three G's
garage
and Garden or whatever it was like like
everyone's gonna have their own model
but just figure out that model is for
you before okay then on balance in
particular I've got two things to share
number one is
I
I have a dashboard that I draw for
myself on the last day of every single
month I draw it on a piece of paper
nobody else sees it except for me and in
the it's a four item dashboard and I use
this dashboard as a way to figure out
whether I'm in or out of balance on a
monthly basis the center of the
dashboard is my icky guy it could change
but right now I write down helping
people live happy lives including myself
that's that's my purpose that's what I'm
trying to do
then there's four quadrants the bottom
two quadrants are uh how I do it and the
top two are what I do so think of four
quadrants the top left quadrant is
called strong core everybody's will be
different for mine it's writing one
article writing one chapter giving three
speeches or whatever it is a month and
those things could be colored in rich
green
yellow or red
okay
then the top right is fastest learning I
want to read eight books per month I
want to have one unique experience I
want to conduct two podcast interviews
and for me I have to prepare for those
podcast interviews as well are they
green are they yellow are they red this
is what I do strong core fastest
learning below that is how I do it there
is what I call best family and best self
best family is
four or more family days per month right
these are things we've talked about
before four more families a month four
or more date nights per month this is
really important in our system if Lassie
and I are connected when we miss the
date nights there's fracturing we're
starting to get chirpy at each other we
haven't had time to connect the two of
us right and there is a third one that I
forget but I color them in yellow
green or red bottom right is best self
number of workouts number of meditations
number of number of of uh of uh runs or
whatever I put in the things that I
think will kind of Infuse myself again
yellow red or green
by coloring in this dashboard at the end
of my month I find balance because
inevitably on every single month there's
a bunch of red somewhere sometimes the
red is on personal I've gone flying
around and I've done all the productive
stuff on my work and that's all green
and I've read a lot of books but you
know I've missed some family dinners and
I haven't been doing my workouts and
there's some red at the bottom that
helps me guide the next month to find
balance now I will invest in the bottom
a bit more I'm back on track with my you
know they're all systems but they're
just helpful guidelines now I'm all
green at the bottom well I haven't
really been written writing a chapter on
my next book that's kind of falling off
the yellow or maybe that falls off to
Red so again this tool helps me find
balance because what I'm doing is I'm
drawing it just for myself it's just a
dashboard I just sent you a picture of
it or show it to you after yeah I'm like
trying to I'm trying to imagine it but
basically what I gather from this is
yeah it's really an exercise in getting
honest with yourself an objective about
your like what your what your kind of
tension is versus the reality of what
you actually did right so you're very
clear like oh I said I was going to do
all these things like I fell short here
and here and it helps you plan for the
next quadrant or period or whatever so
that you can kind of course correct or
wherever that pendulum is a little bit
off in any of those quadrants that are
important to you you can kind of think
about and plan to do better next time
right that's that's and I will never
draw a dashboard probably that's fine
yeah that's fine yeah but you have your
own systems and you you know we talked
about in terms of what you eat we talked
about in terms of drinking we talked
about you we know we know about your
your Fitness and your ex so you're doing
a lot of things like this already baked
in but I I need help and so the
dashboard helps illuminate for me how in
or out of balance I am and it also is
interesting because you know before I
had this like four speeches per month or
whatever it was like some months I'd
have eight and I'd be like wow eight
speeches wow this is like so many this
is so great and but then it was so
obvious that all kinds of stuff falls
off and so the dashboard is meant to be
like the dashboard of a car like you
know it helps you steer yeah which which
gauges are in the red yeah exactly yeah
I mean that was you know with the
speeches thing I mean similar to what
Mel shared like when she was just you
know in such high demand and they were
paying her so much couldn't say no and
she was just on the road all the time
and just crushing it yeah but then all
these other are areas of her life we're
starting to you know fall apart because
she was never home and she had to like
really kind of reconfigure everything to
and figure out a new way of like you
know kind of pursuing her business in
order to maintain her her marriage and
her relationship with her kids and
everything absolutely in terms of your
relationships also at home less than I
do a quarterly meeting so I know it
sounds like a lot no but but it's it if
you plan you publish a quarterly report
also and like do you have a deck that
you share in advance with each other I
actually I actually stole this idea from
Professor David Ulrich at the University
of Michigan because what he does he told
me that every he meets with his wife
once a quarter outside of the home he
said it must be outside of the home
cannot be inside the home this is an
important point it has to be like a
neutral territory because there's no no
one's going to yell or scream at a
restaurant okay so you start off with
the place you start off with a public
place this is like uh tradecraft
it's exactly and then you you have four
headlines I think he said that the four
for him were you know money sex work and
family and each person goes down the
four items and says so on money
how are you feeling about money with us
are you feeling like we're good do you
want to revisit any aspect of how we're
thinking about money let's go through
them each one by one and people you meet
on a quarterly basis oftentimes it helps
prevent fights or arguments in the three
months up to it because Leslie and I
will say to each other let's just have
that let's add that one to our our uh
our quarterly meeting so keep a note add
to quarterly meeting and then we'll have
a topic discuss and then it takes it out
of the situations where we're probably
gonna have a fight where we're both
tired we're both Sleepless it's right at
the end of the night and if we bring it
up then it's not going to get results
and it's going to be messy and and it's
going to be ugly so we just the the
correlate meeting also acts as a bit of
a venting system and a prophylactic
right because you're you're kind of like
airing it out before it becomes so acute
that there's an outburst in a fight wow
and a misunderstanding right wow yeah
but meanwhile you say you'll never do it
yeah I just can't imagine like I I just
but you have your wife all the time so
you you guys I do you're having a
different type of processing what's
hilarious Neil is that like in our
relationship I'm like much more the
systems guy than she is and like I
compared to you like there's no system
right so Julie is just she's surfing the
waves of the you know it's like it
doesn't like and it's and she's an
amazing entrepreneur and like so
talented and she gets so much done and
she's so good at so many things and I'm
like I have to do one thing at a time
and I have to be like all organized and
um and and kind of planning around stuff
it works we've been together forever and
like we you know we're very different
people but there's something about like
the differential in our energies and
approaches that complements each other
but I do have a hard time imagining us
sitting down and having a quarterly yeah
I mean she will be like we need to talk
like let's sit down like we need we have
to go over this stuff like she's pretty
good about that but you do have this
it's just not as like scheduled and
we have a podcast I've listened to your
pockets episodes with Julie I know Julie
I love Julie and like you are processing
things in a different way it happens
different it happens to be public but
like those are quite
those are quite right we have our
private meetings too of course yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean you know I think
the point being like
find what works for you as as you know
as a couple as partners
communication is key what that looks
like for you it's very structured for
other people it might be you know less
so but
um prioritizing communication around
those important things like finances sex
Etc you know yeah child rearing yeah
family or family is like all those times
yeah on you know and on the same page on
those things or you're going to have
problems and if you're just kind of like
whatever about it like you're on a crash
course with you know something's going
to happen it takes a lot of work so it
is when I say like weekly date night too
it's like that sounds like a luxury
actually it's it's an it's a critically
important cause again when you miss it a
week or two in a row then you're nosing
branches start coming up right you
forget that you're you forget you who
you were as a couple before you had kids
yeah and that is a an identity that you
don't want to lose since the kids are
going leave yeah and I will say also on
this Mo on these models and these this
idea of balance one thing that I do
think about is
I think there's a I don't think of it in
a stressful way but I think a timer
starts ticking from the moment you have
your last child to what from that point
to when your first child leaves the
house
and I think there is a finite amount of
time that most families have when all
their nuclear family is Under One Roof
like to our Point earlier about kids
having to choose what they want to do
and maybe going off when they're 17 18
or whatever 19.
and that therefore forces into a macro
level system the idea that this decade
that Leslie are living right now is one
out of ten again that that's nice that's
a nice thing to use where we just have
to be present and prioritizing of our
family and if there's a decision to be
made on X versus y on traveling versus
not but accepting versus saying no it
has to go towards the thing that is more
rare and more sacred and more special
and more scarce and that is the time
with the family Under One Roof which is
a very small amount of time in the grand
scheme of things it's the opposite of
the 20s
right
20s are about kind of being selfish and
and investing in yourself and
exploration and that child rearing you
know decade is really about putting your
own selfish desires aside and really
investing in in uh you know in in these
young people yeah yeah and and what you
will gain from doing that I don't yet
know right but I expect it to be a
fuller richer wiser more informed
worldview that enables again a wonderful
set of decades after that too yeah well
as somebody's further down the line I
will tell you that it's not going to pan
out the way you've imagined it and there
will be lots of you know landmines of
course you know and that's that's a nice
backward level uh point about every
single thing I've talked about from
assistance perspective these are helpful
AIDS they're not and they're not in
permeable tools like they're meant to
enable not not force yeah I mean I think
for me what I get from what you're
saying is is a healthy relationship with
control like if you're setting up these
rules because you're trying to control
your environment and the people around
you and the trajectory of your career
you're in for like a world of hurt and
pain of course and so but if you're
building these systems to create freedom
and allow you know more expansiveness
for you to be in an you know able to
like explore your curiosity and like
engage with the things that you love
um that's great and very different but I
do think I do think that a lot of the
system stuff it lights up the brains of
the people who are who have an unhealthy
relationship with control
um right including me yeah sure yeah and
so yeah that's where it can it can go
sideways I think yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah no it's it's it's
figuring out the balance that works for
you and thinking of everything that we
have talked about so far today as an
offering you know the goal in general is
not to be perfect it's just to be a
little better than before I think that's
something I get from your show this is
my favorite podcast rich I love your
show I listened to it I think it's
wonderful it's beautiful and there's
different things I take from everything
every time and there's stuff that
contradicts and that's okay it's just
figuring out what works for you carrying
it in your pocket using it for as long
as it serves you and then discarding it
as you keep moving I do thank you I
appreciate that and on the subject of
podcasts I did want to spend a little
bit of time talking about your podcast I
got to get you out of here at some point
we've been here forever but not I'm I'm
very happy three books yeah
um I love the premise of the show the
idea is you sit down with these people
and you ask them about uh you know their
three the three books that impacted them
the most I had the the opportunity to be
a guest on your show and I loved it you
were so prepared and I love that it's
very focused in that regard
um but I think the thing that is so
interesting is that this is like a you
know on some level a side project your
main thing which is writing books yeah
and yet in a very short period of time
you've been able to book like incredible
guests like you've got Quentin Tarantino
and you got David Sedaris and like
Malcolm Gladwell and like all these
people like your hustle game is on point
but I also think it it is illustrative
of this principle that we talked about
earlier like the Cy Young Thing of like
just you know like getting up and taking
swings and like like lowering the bar
and not thinking about these you know
tries as failures and I just know in my
own case of running this podcast like I
get all up in my head about asking
people I don't want to ask people to be
on the show I don't want to be you know
rejected or I feel like I'm bothering
them and like you're just like oh I got
hey you know and then you're so generous
like you're like I had Daniels on
they're amazing you should have you know
like you're trying to help me like get
these people on
um I've like been very inspired by like
the Daniels Pat they said no to me but
they did your show which is cool and now
they're probably going to win the Oscar
for best picture but uh I just you know
I have a lot of respect and admiration
for how you kind of have you know
created this this cool thing thanks Rich
I appreciate it you know it's uh it's a
small podcast compared to the Richmond
okay that doesn't matter yeah it's like
I know that's not what I'm talking but
here's what I'm talking about that I
think we're both saying is that
different is different is better than
better so if you when I started three
books it was 2018 at the time there was
two million podcasts available today as
we speaking in 2023 there are over 5
million so your only chance is to be
different your only hope if you for
whatever it is you want to do it's to be
different different is better than
better don't try to compete with like
you know a deep intense video based
long-form conversational Pockets with
this show or Tim Ferriss or Joe don't
don't don't go for that it was just go
for something different and and the
reason I point that out is because
typically when I'm sending the guest an
invitation they're hearing an invitation
that they've never heard before which is
hey Dan Quan and Daniel scheiner would
you like to come on three books and talk
about your three most formative books
there is a huge filter in there right
away if the person's not a bookish
person and I'll tell you there's been
some times where I meet a fascinating
person I get to the point I'm like so
did you read books and they're like no
I'm like damn it then I can't ask them
to come on my show
it's a question that a book nerd
typically hasn't heard before and then
they will love answering because no
one's ever asked them before and
Daniel's being Daniels of course picked
two formative books together no one
belongs here more than you by Miranda
July and um and then they each picked a
formative book themselves just breaking
the constructs of genre once again yeah
and they're they're they were wonderful
and um and then and then for me it's
also just like do you love it so much
you can take the pain and the punishment
too I'm not paying the punishment that I
served myself in this podcast is crazy I
am ha I task myself with reading all the
formative books that the guest has
provided me so you give me the war of
Art and the artist's way and the big
book I actually buy the big book I buy
the war of art I have them on my
bookshelf for like beside my bed for
like weeks I'm paging through them I'm
looking for quotes from this Bill Wilson
thing I'm looking I'm looking okay
what's Julia Cameron saying in the
interviews I'm gonna ask but I I set
myself up an almost internable
unreachable goal that's so high but
guess what I love books I love buying
the books I love flipping through the
front back matter I like going on
Goodreads and finding the most popular
quotes I like going into the depths
there and then that enables a
conversation like we had on three books
which is different for you because
you've probably been on a lot of
conversations with like so tell me about
when you were going up the stairs when
you were 40 rich and you get that so
many times that you don't want to have
that conversation yeah yeah so it's just
so the podcast has this the issue of the
structure it's it's back to the refrain
in general here the structure sometimes
can disable itself like where I have to
yeah but it's just refreshing for the
guests like oh thank God like I can do
this cool thing and talk about something
that I care about and it doesn't have to
be about me and I have to tell that same
story over and over again yeah and I I I
I I and like kudos to Tarantino because
when when he came on and then you were
in his book yeah you got like I forgot
about that like he quoted you in his
book I know it was so it was so it was
so but I'm saying kudos to him because
he's past the point of I think I'm
projecting of like I what I got from
that was that he just wanted to do shows
where he could like just geek out and
have fun and like have big nerdy
conversations and like that's Kudos that
guy not everybody likes that most people
if they start asking me questions about
like okay so what are the downloads you
get and how many followers you have on
Instagram I'm like this is not gonna
work out because right I don't have
Rich's follower account and stuff like
that and not comparing myself to you but
but it's just the the angle that they're
coming in with is not going to enable
where we're gonna go which is down a
really big artistic rabble on what
shaped you from a book perspective and
that's just one idea there's millions of
videos for Pockets but similar to the
Thousand awesome things it's 1 000
formative books collected over 333
chapters it's a finite day it's got a
finite time I publish it only on the
exactment of every new moon and every
full moon okay so I'm this also I don't
recommend because it totally screws you
up on any algorithmic ranking yeah like
you're never on the same day you're
launching Like Mondays and Thursdays
Mel's launching Like Mondays and
Thursdays how many emails I get Mondays
and Thursdays and then suddenly it's
like
Saturday night at two in the morning
calendar exactly
exactly and so yeah just like the blog
like when you get to a thousand books
you're gonna come down yeah so how many
books into it are you now now I'm about
400 books in yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
started in 2018 and it's been a joyous
ride
um I've learned a lot along the way and
uh you know uh what a beautiful world we
live in you know uh I I I I was lucky
enough to interview Dave Eggers on the
show and he said you know uh podcasts
are the antithesis of everything wrong
with the world today he said they are
long they are deep they are cerebral
they are Focus they are they are they
are pulling our focus into an area they
are the anti he talked about podcasts in
such a beautiful Way Rich that made me
feel so good and it's so true no wonder
you're attracted to this medium no
wonder it works for you no wonder it's
the type of conversation that you have
over the years over the guests over and
over again about living uh an
intentional life because the medium
serves that
you're not viral on Tick Tock yeah it
doesn't work that way
um it's a different kind of Engagement
but I think that there is a thirst and a
hunger out there for something that's
that that feels real you know and I
think that we're missing you know we
talked earlier about you know the the
kind of fractured
um you know urban lifestyle that we live
now where our connection to community is
not what it used to be 40 of us live
alone Surgeon General says
in this epidemic of loneliness increased
rates in in in depression and anxiety
and suicide this legitimate Mental
Health crisis that's been exacerbated by
covet of course and covet also uh you
know amplifying our our you know our
kind of uh
um
you know lack of lack of analog contact
with other human beings like even though
we're you know on the back side of that
we acclimated to zoom and all this sort
of stuff and it's like now I don't even
know like like when I try to book
podcast guests they all assume it's a
zoom and then when I'm like oh it's in
person they're like oh you know like
that wasn't the case before the
pandemics
the norm the norm yeah like what's
normal now is like our digital interface
with other human beings and
um
and I think
you know that's driving people to look
for community and connection on these
digital platforms and you know if there
is a a silver lining it's that like we
have this like you know deep-seated need
for that campfire experience and on some
level podcasts serve that they are an
antidote to The Click bait you know
sound bite
um hot take uh you know kind of media
landscape that predominates our you know
consumption of of content and you know
it's that I think that that aspect of it
is really cool well especially if you're
doing what you're doing and actually
putting out really long form long-form
interviews because there is a tendency
even within the median that we're
talking about being civil to be shorter
and more produced and more like there is
pressure is even well now podcasting is
moving towards that that's what I like
yeah like these very kind of like highly
produced and that's a different thing
and I think there's look I still think
we're really early on it's you know I
think podcasting is still a really new
medium so I think there's room for that
and I love those kinds of shows as well
like this is a different kind of thing
but I don't think that this will ever go
out of style you know I think that we
will always have a need to hear two
people you know in a in a conversation
where you know honesty rains you know
like I just I just think that that's
part and parcel of what it means to be
human and if we move too far away from
that we'll always find our way back to
it somehow
I I I I absolutely agree I I have Echoes
of Team Human by Douglas rushkoff in my
ears i i as you know when I started
three books made it so that I come out
of the left ear and the guest comes out
of the right ear I have chia I'm like I
question that decision you told me you
told me correctly to change that and
what I did was using production we made
it sound like the gas was in the front
left and and I was you know we still but
we still if you listen to three books
I've tried to make you the listener feel
like you're literally on the couch
between us and For Better or For Worse I
get a lot of complaints there is some
just yeah like some distribution from
side to side but not entirely one ear in
the other one Dolby thing like exactly I
can kind of tell this person's on that
side of the room I was doing spatial
before Apple got into it yeah yeah
that's interesting well I was trying to
make it make that connection and for me
the podcast is
um
itself it's it's it's self-success it's
not sales success it's not social
success there's three s's there's three
different kinds of success you have to
choose which one you want you have to go
for it if if I was trying to monetize
the podcast it would it would flop I
don't have enough downloads on it to
make it worth the while of
um a big Advertiser I don't athletic
greens is not banging down my door okay
and at the same time I have to keep
coming back to my bearings I don't look
at the stats I do it for myself I do it
for a learning vehicle for people that
love books or want to love books more
it's buy and for Book Lovers writers
maker cells and Librarians and I reason
I come up with that triangle is because
I have to remember that when I don't
have you know when I when I don't have
some of the other elements that can be
very tantalizing
and I do think for anything in life we
were talking about Daniels we're talking
about best picture historically the best
pitcher winner whether that was The Hurt
Locker or whether that was Moonlight is
a box office flop and Alvin and
Chipmunks the squeak well or Fast and
Furious 7 takes home the cake so decide
if you want sales or social or self
they're not the same thing right and
it's a good exercise like it's a
reminder of that right and it goes to
that intrinsic versus an extrinsic
reward system right so here you are
you're like okay I'm doing this thing
remember this is why I'm doing it not
this yeah all these tantalizing kind of
things are out here that could you know
motivate me to make different decisions
about how I'm running this show but I
think that's like a really you know
beautiful
um
you know kind of pursuit of of doing it
for the pure
um you know intrinsic value that it's
giving you and of course it's providing
you with material that I'm sure is going
to find its way and uh you know the
books that you're writing yeah yeah
um and on that subject of like kind of
community to kind of we're going to end
this thing
um we're we're like three hours in and
then it's like oh by the way like new
book that Neil wrote our book of awesome
you know like let's wedge that in
um
the thing you know in this series of of
Awesome books that you've written like
what is different about this is the
community thing like this is really a
book written by your readership right
and it speaks to that campfire thing
like you've created a really you know
beautiful Dynamic community of people
who love what you do and contributed you
know their stories you know around like
you know what they feel is awesome in
their lives these little things that are
the big things and you've kind of
compiled this into this book that
creates like a connectivity like you
know this is not analog these are people
who are out in the world who connect
with you in different ways but these are
the you know interesting cool ways that
we're finding to you know cultivate that
kind of you know connection the S the
social s that you talk about yeah you
know I'm 43 and I'm a very different
headspace than I was when I was 28. so
after my wife left me after my best
friend tickled in life I had to sell the
house I had to move downtown I lost 40
pounds of distress I stopped eating I
stopped sleeping I had black bags under
my eyes I started wearing makeup to work
because I was so embarrassed of how I
looked well you got a hook up for that
right like if you have Covergirl days
like you know you know you get the go-to
source
to match I literally was putting back uh
makeup under my eyes and I started
writing one awesome thing a day and like
I said they were bad when they started
broccoli flower the last crummy triangle
and a bag of potato chips finding five
dollars in your coat pocket here I am 15
years later I'm still doing it every
single night at midnight thousands of
people around the world get my daily
awesome thing email it comes at 1201 am
every single night still today 15 years
later what happened on that website was
the comments exploded so I started using
the comments as my ideas and then
writing the essay below them
fifteen thousand comments have been
received on that website I put a thing
at the back of the first book the book
of awesome send in your awesome thing I
got thousands of people sending in their
suggestions what happened in my own
brain which was I created a sun-like
dent in my universe that created a
magnet for awesome things to come to me
if there's something in your life that
you want and you're listening to this
start it yourself because then people
will gravitate towards you when they're
looking to do that thing that the
pressure and the entries and the
submissions created the volumes of this
book which now serve me I just guide
them I just Spirit them I just I'll take
a page from Julie's book I'm just now
kind of shepherding this thing and even
the awesome thing that probably comes up
tonight at midnight I didn't write it I
put a byline now in the corner of the
person that submitted it because I want
those names on there and us to realize
and hear and feel like there's somebody
else out there that also loves the
feeling of the snow falling on your
eyelashes or that somebody else there
that loves hitting that last string of
green lights when you're late for work
or there's somebody else that I love
that's walking by on this the smell of
the bakery it's like yeah it can be a
little cheesy sometimes or people are
like you know what like I'm not really
feeling like Pollyanna like this but you
know what there's something so
gratifying about exercising yourself
from this pressure and screen and
algorithmically field existence that
we've created and going back to the
simple things that connect us because
that's what makes us human and that's
what makes us special and that's what
ultimately leads to a rich and
fulfilling life
I mean I can't think of a better way to
end this podcast than than with that man
that was beautiful I love you Neil
amazing I love you too rich thank you
you are such a wise and thoughtful
caring compassionate empathetic human
being ah well look who's talking I
learned more more from you than you do
for me it's like it's a real gift to
have your show and your art and your
your beauty out in the world it's it's a
it's a real pleasure thank you so much
for for your friendship and your love
thank you so Neil's latest book is our
book of awesome but he's got lots of
Awesome books out there the happiness
equation is the book that goes deeper
into the happiness stuff that we talked
about his podcast three books you can
check that out uh anywhere else you want
to direct people neil.blog yeah if you I
have I have newsletters that offer all
these things up to people that want them
in their inbox yeah and uh most of your
speaking gigs are like corporate stuff
like are are some of them is there like
a schedule that of our there's some that
are open to the public if you want to
come and yeah yeah do your thing yeah
there there are like sometimes a
literary festival or School those ones
will be public or ticketed and then I'll
do those but yeah it's it's there's 700
conferences A Day in the United States
and so that ends up being the depressed
son in that Universe the corporate world
um all right my friend well uh until
next time appreciate you thanks for
doing this thanks Rich I really
appreciate yours peace